Monal S: Hey, everyone. Good evening, good morning.
Monal S: Morning, guys, good morning.
Monal S: Good morning from Dubai. Yes, good morning from India. Thank you guys, thank you.
Monal S: How do I know VS Code is attached with a correct kernel version?
Monal S: Shantnu, at the end, I told you that,
Monal S: when we create that virtual environment, now we can create with a name. So that name will be populating on the kernel name. Name will be same as kernel name, alright?
Monal S: Just give me a second, Lance.
Monal S: Alright, so, Shantu, using that way, you will be able to understand that there is a correct kernel, okay? Good morning, guys, good morning, good morning.
Monal S: I hope everyone is doing well.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Format is working, that's great.
Monal S: Then you know that is a correct kernel.
Monal S: Yes, yes. Saurup, I want to, but…
Monal S: Let's see what habit we will build. In every batch, we build habit based on how people feels like.
Monal S: You see him? Little dull? Yes, guys.
Monal S: A little less energy, but still…
Monal S: Excited to teach all of you.
Monal S: Alright, everyone, can we get started? Are you guys ready for today's class?
Monal S: I hope everyone knows what is today's agenda.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Today is Python 2.
Monal S: Ready to rock? Yes.
Monal S: Alright, let me share my screen, and
Monal S: As usual, we will start with what are the things. Just let me…
Monal S: Yes, thank you very much, guys.
Monal S: You want to decrease brightness a bit. I really don't like white lights a lot.
Monal S: This feels good.
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys. Thank you, Ano.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Today is 18th.
Monal S: of Jan 2026.
Monal S: today's agenda.
Monal S: We are learning Python again. It is only day 2.
Monal S: Yes, guys, we were able to solve everyone's issue. I have pasted the solution also on our community. Everyone's issue was able to solve, okay?
Monal S: In Python 2, there are things which we are going to learn. The first thing is string properties.
Monal S: I hope everyone now knows what is string. Yesterday, I told you what is a string. Yes?
Monal S: string properties, We are then going to again start operators, but now the advanced version of it, okay?
Monal S: Then… Control flow.
Monal S: Control flow is a concept, but in that concept, we have if-else, other things, alright? So we are going to take a look on that. Then, if you guys will be comfortable on that, I will tell you control flow 2. It means little bit of advance. Nested.
Monal S: nested, okay? This is simple, basic control flow, this is advanced control flow that is nested.
Monal S: Guys, we usually have two recordings because the class is getting longer, so it has to be splitted into two parts.
Monal S: Alright? Is my voice clear, everyone?
Monal S: Is my voice clear? Is my screen… nothing is flickering, everything is smooth? That's great. Guys, I'm confirming, everyone confirmed that. My voice is loud and clear. There is no issue with my… with my screen or my internet. Alright? So whoever is having issue, please do something on that. Yeah, thank you guys.
Monal S: Then, we'll talk about… maybe we can just have a discussion, or we can start based on the time that we have, non-primitive
Monal S: data type.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: the data type that we have learned, we will call it as the Python data type of primitive data type, but I will talk about it, okay? These are the agenda. Is everyone clear? So whoever knows these concepts, they are free to leave and then enjoy the Sunday.
Monal S: They are weekend, but if you know all of this, feel free to stay, okay? Now, we are not going to do any installation. Installation is… everything is done.
Monal S: Alright, so we are just going to jump into the coding part. Alright? That's great. Now, let's get started.
Monal S: Okay, so the first thing is string properties. So let me write string properties.
Monal S: string… properties.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So, we have seen that when we create characters, similar, like, data science, when we write some kind of a sentence, a word, or even a character, that comes with… when you check with the type, we will see something like this. How many of you remember this?
Monal S: When we check the type of it, we get something like this. Yes? Everyone remembers?
Monal S: Alright? So, whatever data type consists a class of STR comes with different, different methods. What is this? I told you, what do we call this?
Monal S: Recall that as a function. It does something.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Just like print is a function, it's a function, we provide something in between, and it does the job.
Monal S: Yes, everyone knows the flow of the function. Function, we provide something, it does the job. Similarly, ID is a function, we provide something, it does some job. What are other functions which we have seen?
Monal S: Guys, I always provide the notes in the class resource and in the community as well.
Monal S: Yes, we have seen type as well. Type is also one of the functions, yes? So everyone is pretty comfortable with what function is.
Monal S: Yes, STR typecasting we have seen. We want to convert something. These are all typecasting things which we have seen.
Monal S: Yes, these all are functions. So let me write, all are functions.
Monal S: And because this is kind of the notes, just for the understanding, I'm going to keep it here.
Monal S: Alright? And let's keep everything here.
Monal S: Just give me a second… Alright.
Monal S: Better notes from the very start will help us build
Monal S: Is this good? Alright, so these are built-in functions. So, similarly, whenever something has, okay, there are other things than class. When we check the type.
Monal S: class also comes with int float, but there are other things which does not have this class. So anything that has a class, anything that has a class also has properties.
Monal S: Alright? Anything that is of type class at the start comes with properties, and we will call those as methods.
Monal S: Are we clear? Functions, these are called as functions. Anything that is a class comes with its own properties. Properties are not common. Properties can be anything. I will talk about it. So, class…
Monal S: a class that is string comes with certain properties. Guys, I will talk about it. Okay, just let me tell you this example. House.
Monal S: Alright? House. What are the properties of house?
Monal S: What are the properties of house? House has doors.
Monal S: House has windows. Yes?
Monal S: House has windows. House has rooms.
Monal S: So, think of house as class. House is a class.
Monal S: So, class always has some kind of a property. House has door, house has windows, house has rooms, house has floors.
Monal S: Similarly, what are functions? Think of functions as, like, just on a high-level overview, we are going to create our own class, but right now, we are using everything that Python gives us. What about functions? If I talk about function, function, let's suppose.
Monal S: A glass. Glass is a function. In glass, you pour water, you drink water from it.
Monal S: Are we clear? So, class is a standalone thing, standalone code, which does something. Class is…
Monal S: class is a compound, or you can say combinations of different functions. So, when we say string.
Monal S: When we say string, a string is a class. A string comes with its own properties.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand? Whenever we have a type, whenever we do something with type, if it comes with a class, it means it has some properties. And now we are going to look at those properties, alright? So, this is…
Monal S: String.
Monal S: Now, a string comes with its own properties.
Monal S: No, guys, class also comes in… if you print the integer flow, there also we have class.
Monal S: But right now, we are talking specifically about string, because there it provides more methods, more useful methods.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Everyone, you will understand.
Monal S: So, string has methods like strip.
Monal S: String has methods like LSTRIP.
Monal S: String has methods like RString.
Monal S: You will understand how we are using all of that, how to differentiate. Guys, functions and methods, we will talk about later, but for now, we will differentiate functions and methods.
Monal S: Think of function as standalone code.
Monal S: Think of method as… it's a part of some other block.
Monal S: This is… we will call this as method.
Monal S: We will call this as function.
Monal S: Is everyone able to visualize at least the difference between function and method?
Monal S: At least, are you able to visualize? So, if this is a string block, it will have multiple methods.
Monal S: Function can be… type is a function.
Monal S: It is a standalone thing.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Guys, I will repeat again.
Monal S: I will repeat again.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Because I'm introducing the word of method, that's why a lot of people get confused, but if I started without even giving you the basics, it will be simpler.
Monal S: Okay, see this.
Monal S: Now, guys, don't worry about the difference. Understand how we use it, okay? Understand how we use it. See this. First, I will give you a demo, then you will understand, alright? Everyone?
Monal S: It's fine, guys.
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: This is our lectures.
Monal S: This is our lectures, and in this lecture, what I'm going to do, this zip, I have already provided to all of you, I'm going to delete it, and in this lecture, I'm going to create a new folder where we'll be doing today's coding. 18012026. No one should say, sir, I don't know how to create these folders and others. This is already completed.
Monal S: Guys, you will see that, you will see that. See this. I'm going to create a new file, I'm going to rename it as 18012026.ipynb.
Monal S: Nope.
Monal S: Everyone, focus.
Monal S: So what I'm drawing…
Monal S: This is level 1 I've selected, and in the markdown, I will be starting first string operations.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So, see this. When I do type, this is in Markdown, I need code block.
Monal S: when I do type of 1, I am getting int.
Monal S: When I'm getting type of data, a string.
Monal S: I'm getting this. Now let's print it, because sometimes a lot of the functionality gets hidden. Now this looks better.
Monal S: So, are we able to understand the functionality of type?
Monal S: Type, you provide something, it gives you data. It gives you answer. Is this part clear?
Monal S: Is this part clear? Everyone?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So now, see this data. Tell me what is this data type of this string?
Monal S: What is this? This is what?
Monal S: What should we call this?
Monal S: This is a string.
Monal S: Now see what I'm doing. Now see what I'm doing. As I mentioned, string is what? String is a class. Yes?
Monal S: A string is a class itself.
Monal S: If I talk about this type, type is what? Type is a function. This value which we're talking about is a string, it is class. Now, see what I'm doing.
Monal S: Let me write…
Monal S: Are we able to see there are a lot of spaces?
Monal S: Front and and… Are you able to see a lot of spaces, front and end?
Monal S: Alright, now see the output.
Monal S: In the string, I'm using something called as dot.
Monal S: then I'm using its function, its method.
Monal S: Are we able to see any spaces now?
Monal S: Are we able to see any spaces?
Monal S: So this is a class called a string, and we are using its own property.
Monal S: Its own property is called as method.
Monal S: Is this a different property? Can I use a strip? See this. Strip is not a function. If I provide strip and provide data science, it will not work.
Monal S: It is giving you error here itself. Are you able to see?
Monal S: Because it is not a function.
Monal S: It's a property of… string itself.
Monal S: So, a property of something is called as method.
Monal S: But a standalone thing, standalone thing which does some job is called as function.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: The standalone thing, which does some job, is called as function.
Monal S: something which is a part of another thing that is a string, right? Here, it is a part of… this is a property… strip is a property of string.
Monal S: If I apply 1.strip, it will not work.
Monal S: Because 1 is integer, strip is a property of… guys, tell me. Strip is a property of…
Monal S: Strip is a property of… correct. Everyone is not correct. Strip is a property of string.
Monal S: If I run it, it will say invalid, it does not know this is a integer, it does not know what this property is. That's why it is creating error. But if I enclose one with double quotes, make it as a string, it will work, it will not do anything, because everything is correct.
Monal S: So is everyone able to understand this part which I was talking about?
Monal S: Certain class has certain properties.
Monal S: Your car is a class, has property like drive.
Monal S: Open door.
Monal S: Your house is another class, but does house have a property of drive?
Monal S: Does house has a property of drive?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: How's will I have lived rooms, etc.
Monal S: If I talk about door alone, door alone, very small component.
Monal S: Indoor, we provide something, it gets something.
Monal S: That's all. Door does not have any property. What we call that in Python, in programming language, what are we going to call this?
Monal S: What are we going to call this? A function.
Monal S: Is everyone clear between function and properties? Properties and methods, okay? We say these are methods, but methods of some class.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: I will write in comments, not a function.
Monal S: Alright? And then here, little confusing, guys, what is confusing? Tell me.
Monal S: Here, I will call it as… A strip is, property of string.
Monal S: Bhavan, we can say that, but right now, I'm just giving example.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Methods and functions, guys.
Monal S: Guys, no doubt.
Monal S: Now, note this down.
Monal S: If I don't give you a definition, you guys will not understand.
Monal S: Methods.
Monal S: Property of something is… Called a method.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Property of something is called a method function.
Monal S: You can see…
Monal S: does something.
Monal S: Okay? Does some job.
Monal S: Function does some job, method also does some job, but method… the main thing about method is, method can only be utilized against its own property, like a string.
Monal S: Alright? So if I talk about class of string.
Monal S: Everyone see this. I am again repeating.
Monal S: A string has its own property. Property, think in terms of property. Don't consider method as a word. String has certain properties. Properties of strip, properties of L strip, properties of r strip.
Monal S: Integer, on the other hand, does not have a strip.
Monal S: Alright? Integer, on the other hand, does not have these properties, so we cannot use strip with integer.
Monal S: Is this part clear? What properties are…
Monal S: Is this part clear? Don't forget about function for now. Are we clear, everyone? Are we clear what is a property?
Monal S: Property is tightly coupled with its own class.
Monal S: Classes, string, Its own data type. Think of that as its own data type.
Monal S: Depends on data type.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: What is a function?
Monal S: Function does not have… function is not coup… okay.
Monal S: function, not… Related to data type.
Monal S: Function is not related to data type. Function job is… It does something.
Monal S: Alright? Yes. Right now, if I say block of code, then people will say, what is a block? Alright?
Monal S: So, say this? Here, what I'm doing, ID.
Monal S: If I say ID of a variable, A is equal to 2. If I provide A,
Monal S: What we are doing, what we are doing, we are asking this piece of code, which we have seen, and does something.
Monal S: Does it have… are we using anything like dot or something? If we are not using anything like dot or something, which we were using before, it means it is not a method. Only consider that whenever we use dot against something, it is called as method.
Monal S: Whenever we are using something like dot, it is a method. When we are not using dot, it is a function. When we are going into object-oriented programming, then you will understand the main difference between function and method, but right now, I just wanted to tell properties of… properties of…
Monal S: data, that is a string, int float is called as method. If we don't use that property that is dot, it means it is not a method. Function, it does something.
Monal S: Alright? Here, what it is doing?
Monal S: does something… But… only… for its… own data type.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Guys, tell me, okay, people are asking, can't we call a function with a dot to perform something? See this. This is ID.
Monal S: Can I call A.ID? Let's see.
Monal S: Is it working?
Monal S: It means ID is not a property of variable.
Monal S: It means ID is not a property of…
Monal S: Integer. Are we able to understand?
Monal S: Guys, ID is not a property of integer. Are we able to understand?
Monal S: Yes, devices.
Monal S: So don't complicate too much, just understand that when we use dot, it is a property of something.
Monal S: ID is a function. Function cannot be used with dot.
Monal S: Function cannot be used with a dot.
Monal S: Alright, so let me write…
Monal S: Cannot be used with this dot.
Monal S: Hey, Ed?
Monal S: we use dot… To call its property.
Monal S: Don't worry, guys, you will get familiar.
Monal S: Okay? You will get familiar. Alright? So, now let's get started on this end part.
Monal S: Guys, property and methods. Yes, property and methods is same, I'm just using it interchangeably, okay? Method is the main technical term, property is what, we use it as a concept.
Monal S: Yes, yes, Sanjit.
Monal S: Sanjit, do you mind not really doing all of that, I'm able to read it.
Monal S: property, Vikram. Alright. So, let's create a variable name.
Monal S: Okay, let's create a variable name, and here I have monol, S, and a lot of spaces.
Monal S: And a lot of spaces. The first property which we will do is…
Monal S: The first property which we will do is, it's called a strip. A strip is a property of a string, this is something which you need to remember, alright? Now, if I apply name.strip, name.strip, what it does? What it does? It removes, it removes spaces.
Monal S: From right and left side of the… right and left side of the string.
Monal S: Is this part here known?
Monal S: When we use name.strip, it removes spaces. I have spaces, this is empty space. Here I have space, no space. But it… the main job of this method is to remove spaces from left and right side of the string.
Monal S: And now, see what I will do? I will save it again back to name.
Monal S: So whatever is removed, I will save it again, and let's print and see what happens.
Monal S: Print name.
Monal S: Name is not defined because I need to run this cell.
Monal S: Is it working? Are we able to see any space? See, when you select it, you will see the actual, actual text. Are you able to see that space?
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: Panic departs.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Guys, don't go too much in depth. Right now, when we learn object-oriented programming, then we will understand. But I am… I'm giving you at least some information that you can relate later. Just use dot strip with a string, for now.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: You will understand later.
Monal S: Name.strip. Now, there is another function called as lstrip.
Monal S: It is… L strict, okay? But before writing anything, let me conclude so that we know the actual concept.
Monal S: To remove white spaces, To remove white spaces from string, we use… Below matters.
Monal S: Everyone know when I say methods. It means it belongs to a certain data type, alright? First is L strip.
Monal S: L strip means removes… a space… From left side.
Monal S: Only left side. Is this part clear?
Monal S: Similarly, we have Rstrip. How many of you are able to guess it? What RStrip is going to do?
Monal S: What RStip is going to do?
Monal S: Removes… a space from… Right side. Correct. Right side.
Monal S: And then we only have strip.
Monal S: A strip is a combination of L strip, plus R strict.
Monal S: It removes left, it removes light, and it makes it as a string.
Monal S: Are we clear? Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Alright? So, say this.
Monal S: Again, I'm going to… let's create a new name, okay? Let's create a new name. Here, I have only on the left side. Okay, I have on the both side, and this time I will use… I will not save it back to name.
Monal S: But we will be able to print it.
Monal S: name.rstrip.
Monal S: If I select it, are we able to see the left space is still left, but the right part is gone? Yes?
Monal S: Are we able to see this?
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Similarly, I will show you our strip now.
Monal S: Our strip.
Monal S: And this time, okay, this was already R script, now we will show you L shift.
Monal S: Now, only the left side space will be removed, our side space, we will see, okay?
Monal S: Let me select it. Are we able to see? Left side is gone, right side is here.
Monal S: Are you able to see this?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Guys, right now, we are not able to see the string, because this is how it works in Notebook. If I remove this…
Monal S: Then we will see this… The single quotes.
Monal S: But if I use print, as I mentioned, print does not have these codes. Print just uses values.
Monal S: So if you don't want to use print, let me comment it so you guys can refer it later. It will show you what is going on with those comps.
Monal S: This is a behavior of notebook, but in reality, you will not get these quotes when you run in terminal.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Are we clear? Guys, we have to remember all of this behavior.
Monal S: Alright? Is everyone clear now? If you don't know Strip, can you make Strip? How many of you will be able to create a strip if they only know RStrip and L strip?
Monal S: How many of you will be able to remove complete spaces from left and right without using strip?
Monal S: I will tell you how.
Monal S: The problem statement is remove space from… both side… from both sides, without using… strip.
Monal S: So, what we will do, we will first take the variable, everyone, we will first take the variable, alright? Then, here what we will do, name is equals to name.lstrip.
Monal S: This will remove. Guys, this will remove.
Monal S: the left space.
Monal S: Alright, next. Don't worry, I will make it, I will merge it as well.
Monal S: Then, I will do R strip, save it back to name.
Monal S: If I print name, what will happen? If I print name, what will happen?
Monal S: Both left side is removed, right side is removed, and we will just see the complete string.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Another method, another way to do it, simpler, without using all of this code, what we can do, I will copy it.
Monal S: Here, I will use R string.
Monal S: And that's it.
Monal S: Name.lstrip.rstrip, done.
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: Still working It's still working, now I will tell you how.
Monal S: Guys, I will tell you, first, understand ABCD of programming. The more we know what we can do, the better we will understand when to use it.
Monal S: Say this. On this code, how to read it?
Monal S: Name is…
Monal S: Let's suppose name is data, and we have a lot of spaces. Here we have a space, here we have a space.
Monal S: This is name.
Monal S: When we provide name here, name will be… data.
Monal S: What we are asking Python to do? Name.lstrip.
Monal S: what it will do, it will remove the left side, and we will be left with… and we will be left with this part of data. Yes?
Monal S: Is this part done?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand? Now, what is the… what is the value of… what is the value of this operation?
Monal S: This operation value is this.
Monal S: What we are doing on this value?
Monal S: dot r strip.
Monal S: So this value.rstrip will give you… data.
Monal S: Alright guys, it also happens like this.
Monal S: Now, this is a great question which people are asking.
Monal S: People are asking that.
Monal S: Will it not work right to left? Why is it working left to right? Yes?
Monal S: Say this, everyone?
Monal S: So… First of all, this code execution happens from top to bottom.
Monal S: and right to left. This part is correct. We are doing right to left here, but within this, this is a whole code statement.
Monal S: If I start from here, do I have even the variable to perform?
Monal S: Do I even have the variable where I have to perform?
Monal S: Variable is starting from here, guys. So, when we have operation, within operation, this is right to left is done. Now, within right, we have some sentence. Similarly, happens, like, in the print statement.
Monal S: Okay? Variable is there. What Python does internally, it first solves whatever things it can solve. If A is equal to 12, then it will replace the A and reduce the complexity. Once the complexity is reduced, then it will do its job.
Monal S: So here, name will be replaced with its value, then it will start doing its job.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: So start from the variable, then property, then what property is next?
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: There is a space between… alright, alright, see guys, when we talk about this space, alright, the space in between.
Monal S: Strip is not meant. Guys, when we talk about strip, strip only means from the end.
Monal S: A strip does not remove space from here, a strip only removes space from the end of the string.
Monal S: Guys, you can use R strip, then L strip, totally fine.
Monal S: What you are trying to do is totally depends on you.
Monal S: You can also use R strip and L strip, what difference it will make. First, focus on what exactly it is used for. I have reduced the remove… I have reduced the right side, then I will reduce the left side.
Monal S: Rahul, not here.
Monal S: All right?
Monal S: Alright, very simple.
Monal S: Very simple.
Monal S: Is it simple or not?
Monal S: Muhammad, don't worry about right-to-left execution.
Monal S: Just understand, line by line.
Monal S: Right, to left, and if right is a complex code, then within it, it will start from left to right.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Line by line, that is top to bottom.
Monal S: Then, within top to bottom, we have 3 major components. 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: This value should be going, that is, assignment operator going to the name. Now, if this is a complex system, now we will… Python will start solving it, and to solve it, it requires value. Where is the value? This is the value. What operation? This is the operation.
Monal S: This will give you new value. New value, what operation? L string.
Monal S: Alright? So this completes the first part that we have talked about, that is string properties. In future, there are a lot of properties, guys, which we are going to learn, but this is the introduction of what we will be able to do.
Monal S: Yes, that is another property, Mustan, that's what they were talking about, yes? So, guys, these are not just only properties, string has more properties, but we'll talk about that in future. If you want to see those properties, I will show you.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: dust wait.
Monal S: Let me see if I'm able to see that.
Monal S: Because for it to select.
Monal S: Wait, okay?
Monal S: Let me see if I'm able to open all of that. Okay.
Monal S: Don't worry about all of this code, okay? Don't worry about it, but are we able to see STR
Monal S: Are we able to see STR?
Monal S: Alright, now see all of these properties of SDR. Here, you will also find our split
Monal S: R strip, are you able to see our strip?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: R strip is there. Similarly, you can see there are lots of properties of strip. Not everything, but there are a lot of properties. But for now, we want to just get familiar with few of them. Strip, L strip, R strip.
Monal S: Now, what is the use case? I will tell you what is the use case. Suppose you are a developer.
Monal S: Suppose you are a developer, You will be developer, alright? You are a developer.
Monal S: And you are collecting data from Google Form.
Monal S: You are collecting data from people, Google from, alright? And you have seen in coding that
Monal S: If I talk about data, data is not same as this data. Data is not same as this data.
Monal S: And data is not same as this data, this one has space.
Monal S: Do we agree? Do we agree?
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: Agree? So, it is not same. So, in some of the fields, if I'm asking some people age, okay, I am asking people age. If they pass 27, 28, 40, 50, it is fine.
Monal S: I can use… I can use, if they are passing a string, how to convert to number? Guys, if they are passing a string, can we convert this to a number? We have seen yesterday using typecasting. I can just pass int and the value of a string of 27, it will give me 27, which is a number.
Monal S: But if they pass me 27 space, now this int does not know what to do with the space. It will not be able to convert. So before passing to here, what we will do.
Monal S: Before passing here, what we will do? Can we pass… 27 to first strip.
Monal S: Then we can pass the answer of this to the integer. Can we do that?
Monal S: This string.strip, it will provide a new value, without the spaces.
Monal S: When we pass to integer, will it fix it?
Monal S: Will it fix? It will fix.
Monal S: Alright? So, we will learn. People are asking that what happens if there is a space between this?
Monal S: We will learn more methods that time.
Monal S: We will learn more methods that time, but for now, we are not going to learn it, alright? Keep it simple.
Monal S: Keep it simple. Everyone now knows the use case.
Monal S: Everyone clear with the use case?
Monal S: No, methods are used for a lot of things, alright?
Monal S: This method is nothing but property.
Monal S: Okay? Method is nothing but property.
Monal S: Later in the class, we will… we will learn to create our own class.
Monal S: We will learn to create our own class and methods, we will create our own, not just Python. This one, Python is giving. We will create more of our own, but that is advanced part, not now.
Monal S: Alright? So let's jump to the next part.
Monal S: I know this took more time, but the main part is everyone should be able to understand text. Operators, too.
Monal S: Alright? What is the one operator which we have already learned? Tell me. What is the one operator which we have already learned?
Monal S: operators.
Monal S: We have already completed arithmetic operators.
Monal S: This is already done.
Monal S: What was the next one in the list?
Monal S: Can someone tell me what was the next one in the list?
Monal S: If you go to less study lecture, you will be able to see what we were talking about
Monal S: Where is it? I hope everyone is completing their assignments. I have given the assignment.
Monal S: Alright? The next one is relational operators. Very, very, very important.
Monal S: All the operators are important, alright?
Monal S: So, let me give you that example.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Just wait.
Monal S: Fuck it.
Monal S: Relational, alright? We will go with relational.
Monal S: Next, we have is… Relational operator.
Monal S: Relational operator is also called as comparison operator.
Monal S: It has two names.
Monal S: Comparison operator, and you will understand why.
Monal S: Okay? You will understand why. So now, let's go to this page. Here, I will write whatever things we have completed on the operator, and now I will write relational.
Monal S: Very simple.
Monal S: Everyone knows how to communicate this in real world in our own language, but now we will understand the language of programming.
Monal S: What is the relationship between 12 and 3?
Monal S: Tell me, what is the relationship between 12 and 3? Is 12 bigger, 3 smaller, both of them are equal? What is the relationship in terms of numbers?
Monal S: 12 is greater than 3.
Monal S: What is the relationship between 12 and 12?
Monal S: They are equal. But can I write equal in our coding?
Monal S: Equal is assignment operator. So, encoding, to tell something is equal, we use double equals to.
Monal S: What is the relationship between 3 and 12?
Monal S: 3 is smaller than 12.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: This is done.
Monal S: Alright? This part is done. Now… Another one, okay?
Monal S: So, if I need to find… What is the relationship between Okay.
Monal S: Alright, these are the basic operators. This means… greater than… This means… equals… This means… A smaller than…
Monal S: Now, because we are dealing with… because we are dealing with coding, we will get some more type of situations. We might face a situation where, if I talk about 10, I don't want to understand between 10 and… okay.
Monal S: greater.
Monal S: Then, OR equals 2.
Monal S: If I want to solve this kind of a condition, where I want to find whether certain number is greater than or equals to.
Monal S: How many of you have heard this? This we all use.
Monal S: If I want a situation where I need to tell something is greater than or equals to.
Monal S: It means it should be either greater or equals. In both the condition, it should be…
Monal S: It should solve us, it should give us.
Monal S: Alright? So…
Monal S: In this kind of cases, we use something called as 12 is greater than or equals to 3.
Monal S: Are we clear? This is also true.
Monal S: 12 is. Now, if I want to solve a condition where I will say smaller than or equals to.
Monal S: Smaller than or equals 2.
Monal S: is smaller than or equals 2. I will write 3 is smaller than or equals to 12.
Monal S: Is this also correct?
Monal S: Finally, another operator which tells us, if I want to understand whether something is not equals to something.
Monal S: Don't worry, everything will get cleared. When to use it, where to use it. NOT equals 2.
Monal S: In Python, we use something like this. This we call it as NOT, this will be equals to.
Monal S: So, is 3 not equals to 12? Yes, correct.
Monal S: Now, I will tell you where and how to use it. Relational operators will tell you relation… off…
Monal S: two values.
Monal S: Alright? Relation of two values.
Monal S: And we use operator…
Monal S: And we use operator… to check… If… It is… True or not.
Monal S: True or not is the final goal. So, true or not means True or false?
Monal S: Now, everyone will answer with me.
Monal S: Everyone will answer Mitvi.
Monal S: First value, second value, alright? Everyone will answer with me. Very simple.
Monal S: 12 greater than 3. 2 or false?
Monal S: 12 greater than 3. True or false? True.
Monal S: 12 is smaller than 3. True or false?
Monal S: False!
Monal S: 12, greater than or equal to 3.
Monal S: True or false?
Monal S: Yes, it is not equal, but it is greater than. As I told you, either one of them should be present. It is not equals to 3, 12 is not equals to 3, but here we have 2 operators. Is it greater than? Yes. True.
Monal S: Is 12 smaller than or equal to 3?
Monal S: Is it 12?
Monal S: Is… now, this one is tricky.
Monal S: Age 12, Naught equals to 12.
Monal S: This is how you should solve it, because at the very start, when we start coding, it kind of gives us confusion. So, think of this as opposed of equals.
Monal S: Solve this as… Opposite of double equal.
Monal S: So, let's solve double equal. Is 12 equals to 12? Tell me. Is 12 equals to 12?
Monal S: True.
Monal S: Opposite of true is?
Monal S: Opposite of true ways?
Monal S: False.
Monal S: And what is opposite? Opposite is not.
Monal S: So, when we say 12 not equals to 12, the answer is false. It means we are asking, is this number not equals to this number? No. This number, no. See, the first what I said is, is this number not equals to this number? The first thing is, no. Comma.
Monal S: This is equal.
Monal S: Are you able to understand?
Monal S: Guys, don't answer in the community chat, alright?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand?
Monal S: Final, tell me, is 3 equals to 3?
Monal S: True or false?
Monal S: Again, I'm just cross-cautioning everyone, okay?
Monal S: Is 3 greater than or equal to 3?
Monal S: Someone said no, and someone said false. I was looking. Guys, 3 is not greater than 3, that is…
Monal S: False. 3 greater than 3? False. But here we have two things.
Monal S: Either of them should be correct.
Monal S: 3 is not greater, but 3 is equals, so that is true, that's why I'm asking question.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand all of this?
Monal S: Everyone.
Monal S: Now, let's con… let's take this into our code. This is 18…
Monal S: And here, we will write operators. What operators we are learning currently?
Monal S: what operators?
Monal S: Relational operators, guys, arithmetic is already done. Relational operators.
Monal S: And I want to make it small, so this one, okay?
Monal S: Relational, see this, when to use it?
Monal S: I have variable A, I have variable A called as 100. Let's say 100. This is Marlborne, let me select Python. Don't worry, you will learn to navigate all of that. I have another value called as 200.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Now, let's see this operation. I will print one by one. I will print each one by one to understand the value.
Monal S: I will write A greater than B, small a, because capital A does not exist.
Monal S: Correct?
Monal S: Is this correct?
Monal S: Now, I want all of you, I will write a few things, I want all of you
Monal S: To understand, we already know the behavior, I already repeated it.
Monal S: This is how we do encoding.
Monal S: I'm giving you one… I'm giving you a few seconds, 30 seconds, 40 seconds, to understand
Monal S: And understand each of everything, why the output is coming. We all know the answer, I just want you to look at it.
Monal S: 30 seconds, guys.
Monal S: If you're able to understand, say, done.
Monal S: In the chat We've already done this in our notebook, in our… when I was… where I was writing.
Monal S: Pretty simple.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Similarly.
Monal S: If A is data, B is… data space.
Monal S: And let me zoom in, and if I write FA, is equals… not if, sorry.
Monal S: We're introducing new thing.
Monal S: Bad habit.
Monal S: 4 should be false, 1, 2, 3, 4. Why this one should be false?
Monal S: Let's see if I… if I write it like 100 is smaller than or equals to 200.
Monal S: It is true, guys.
Monal S: It is true.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Okay, so now tell me, all of this we were doing with numbers. With numbers, it makes sense. Greater than, smaller than.
Monal S: Greater than or equals to, smaller than or equals to.
Monal S: Does it make sense, in terms of string, that this data is greater than this data?
Monal S: Does it make sense?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: But… Can we use one of the operators which makes sense?
Monal S: If both of the strings are equal or not, yes.
Monal S: Just going to give you one very simple example, which you guys can relate. Let's suppose this is our ID. This is our ID, okay? Your ID is 123. Your password is…
Monal S: Your password is… Hello, 1, 2, 3. Or let's say hello world.
Monal S: Now, you can create a system, you can create a system to check if ID.
Monal S: I'm just giving you in future things, alright? Or let's just write in print, if ID is equals to whatever your actual ID is. You can later take it, but are you able to at least visualize? Let's suppose our ID should be equals to 100. If it is not, it will give us false.
Monal S: If our password If our password is not equals to… Krishnak Academy.
Monal S: Then we will give false.
Monal S: It means password is not matching, ID is not matching. Is everyone able to relate?
Monal S: Is everyone able to relate? And guys, good question, see this.
Monal S: This is giving us blue.
Monal S: Yes, but the password is white. But if I use ID underscore, it is white.
Monal S: I told you it is not a good thing to write keywords as a variable name.
Monal S: Are we clear? So we can make it as ID underscore, which is not a keyword. Now it is turning to white.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand the future use case? Future is not that simple, guys. It will have lot of things, but at least are you getting the direction?
Monal S: Where can we use it, what can we do? Or suppose you are creating your own system where you don't want people, let's say you want age threshold.
Monal S: age threshold is equals to 18. You don't want people, so suppose if some person 1, person 1 age is 16. They are logging in in your system, like Facebook system or something, what you will first check? You will first check whether the person is
Monal S: person threshold age is correct. So, if person age is smaller than age threshold.
Monal S: Then we will not them log in.
Monal S: Then we will not… not let that person log into our system.
Monal S: Only, see this, person age is smaller.
Monal S: Or we can… here, we can say…
Monal S: If person age is greater than or equal to, then only we will let them log in.
Monal S: Logging is full. When the person will become 18,
Monal S: We will let them in our system.
Monal S: Are we clear? Are we able to understand?
Monal S: Everyone, are we able to… are we able to relate to the real world?
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Tech, non-tech, I'm asking everyone.
Monal S: Okay? So you, as a developer, have total control of your system, what you want to do, what variable you want to create, everything. Clear from non-tech, that's great, Praveen, alright? So, we have completed this. Now, the next part is, we will jump to the next
Monal S: operators, alright? The next one that we have is…
Monal S: assignment operator, alright? This one is a little tricky for at the start, Assignment Operator.
Monal S: All right.
Monal S: So these are the operators which is used to assign values. So if I write A is equal to 2, it means…
Monal S: We are assigning the value of 2 to a variable called as A. Are we clear? Are we clear how to read this?
Monal S: Everyone clear how to read this?
Monal S: Guys, tell me fast.
Monal S: Guys, you are saying no?
Monal S: This is literally the second class.
Monal S: We are assigning the value of 2 to a variable called as A.
Monal S: We did this on day one.
Monal S: Next kind of assignment operator.
Monal S: Plus equals to 2.
Monal S: plus equals to 2, or let's say plus equals to 1. Let's see how to read it. Everyone, very important, everything is going to be the same. Alright? Everything is going to be the same.
Monal S: Assignment.
Monal S: Assignment Operator.
Monal S: Yes, guys. No, no, no, that is not same.
Monal S: Say this, we have seen A is equal to 2. It means
Monal S: It means we are assigning the value of 2 to A. When I write A plus equals to 2, guys, there is a difference. I am not writing A plus 2 is equals to something.
Monal S: Are we able to understand? See this?
Monal S: If you expand this to Python, see this, how to read it. This means A is equals to A plus 2.
Monal S: Everyone, please…
Monal S: understand, try to understand this, very simple. Plus equals is together. When we unroll it to the Pythonic way, this means
Monal S: A is equals to A plus 2.
Monal S: So, it assumes that A's already have some value, Are we clear?
Monal S: So we will first initialize the value of A, then we will do this operation.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: So, in order to… because if I don't write… if I don't write A equals to 2, then write this, what will happen? Python will first see this code, top to bottom, right to left.
Monal S: This is operation right, operation left. It will go from here to here. Then it will start solving the right side. In right side, we will see A.
Monal S: If A does not have any value, Python will say, where is A? I don't know A. Are you able to understand, guys? Top to bottom, right to left, then within operation, we go from left to right.
Monal S: A, let's do.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: It does not know it.
Monal S: So, it needs a value. Similarly, we have A minus equals to 2. It means…
Monal S: A is equals to A minus 2.
Monal S: We have A divided by equals to 2. It means A is equals to A divided by 2.
Monal S: We have A, asterisk means multiplication is equals to 2. This means A is equals to A multiplied by 2.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this?
Monal S: Just the way we write, but how we read it is what we are learning.
Monal S: You can also co-write the code, it is totally fine. Guys.
Monal S: The only advantage it gives you is…
Monal S: You don't have to write this long code, you can do this with one less letter.
Monal S: Both of them does the same job, it's totally up to you whether you want to use this or use this. Both of them are equal.
Monal S: Both of them are equal. Here we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Monal S: Five words.
Monal S: 1, 2, 3, 4, 4th.
Monal S: If this confuses you, then use this. If you like this, use this.
Monal S: Guys, how to read this?
Monal S: I literally told you how to convert it.
Monal S: A multiplication is equals to 2 is same as…
Monal S: This is how we read it. A is equal to A multiplied by 2.
Monal S: So, the operation we perform should be the first
Monal S: Character here in the operation set.
Monal S: Second is assignment.
Monal S: You cannot switch it.
Monal S: What does this mean? If I write A is equal to minus 2, it means A is equals to…
Monal S: What's… how should I write it?
Monal S: Okay, this is not how it works. So, everyone, all the things, you can see, all of them are following a standard. Standard means what operation you want to perform? Addition. What do you want to do after that? Assignment.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Alright, see this. Now let's code.
Monal S: So what should be the value? If A was 2 originally, what should be the value here? What should be the value of A? Let me unroll it. A is equals to A plus 1.
Monal S: What should be the new value of A, everyone? If A was 2 before, what should be the new value of A?
Monal S: A was 2, plus 1 will give you 3. 3 will be in present in A. So this operation will give you update in the A itself.
Monal S: Is this clear?
Monal S: Similarly, if I do minus equals to what will happen.
Monal S: What should be the new value of A?
Monal S: Guys, we are updating the value, that's why it is A equals to A minus 1. It should be 2.
Monal S: Guys, we are just doing subtraction of minus 1 from the original A.
Monal S: It was 3 before, see, it changed the value.
Monal S: A is equals to A plus 1, we are changing the value, yes or no?
Monal S: When we were changing the value, now A has become 3. It is not… it was 2 here. It became 3 here, it became 2 here.
Monal S: This is where we are initializing the value.
Monal S: Sitaram?
Monal S: We are initializing here.
Monal S: Now…
Monal S: What should be the value of A?
Monal S: Tell me what should be the value of A. It is 2 here. If I multiply it by 2, I should get 4.
Monal S: I'm getting 4? Yes.
Monal S: If I do this, what should be the value?
Monal S: 2 again.
Monal S: But it is getting flowed because we are using single.
Monal S: Now, if I show you this, What should be the value?
Monal S: Guys, why will you get 0? 2 divided by 2 will give you 1,
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Guys, for DSA, I will tell you some good news, but floor division.
Monal S: Yes. Sir, one question, why the operator plus, minus, and asterisk you used before,
Monal S: use before equal. Can we use after equal? Guys, this is how the way. Now, this is a question like this.
Monal S: Sir, can you write your name like this?
Monal S: I can write it, but does it make sense?
Monal S: My name is this, this is the way I write my name.
Monal S: This is the way we write these operators.
Monal S: There is no other way. This is what developers who created this language created the standard way. If it is not standard, Python will be confused. You're telling Python, use this, use this, I mean both of them to be same. Now, Python will get confused.
Monal S: Are we able to understand? So, whenever we are doing coding, we always want to maintain a standard across.
Monal S: Is everyone clear? Always the standard.
Monal S: For people who came from
Monal S: Different one. In Python, we don't have A++. This is what we use in C++, C, but we don't have in Python. That is not an operator.
Monal S: Java also.
Monal S: Everyone clear with the relational operators?
Monal S: Everyone claim with the relational operators. Very simple, guys, very simple.
Monal S: What is the next operator that we have? Okay, assignment, sorry, we did assignment.
Monal S: Guys, how many of you don't know this?
Monal S: How many of you don't know this slash and double slash?
Monal S: It means, from the day one, you guys are not revising.
Monal S: It means from the day one, you guys are not revising.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Assignment is done, logical. Alright? Assignment is done, logical is next, logical is little advanced.
Monal S: And, just give me a second.
Monal S: Just give me a second, alright?
Monal S: Yes, I am back. Alright?
Monal S: Sir, if you're using slash output view 1, it is the way it is printing for you, alright? But this is how it should work. If I show you here, if you divide A, which is here.
Monal S: by… Let's say 0.3.
Monal S: We still get without precision, yes?
Monal S: Priya?
Monal S: Are we getting any point?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: It shows you, like, a flow, but it does not retain the precision value.
Monal S: It is not working for you, Surya, Python will work the same for each and every one of you.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Okay, logical operator.
Monal S: Type error cannot concatenate, it means you are doing something weird. Surya, I will show… check your code. You are doing something weird, for sure. Tell me… show me your code, copy and paste your code here.
Monal S: logical operator.
Monal S: Guys, do I need to repeat this?
Monal S: I told you this in the class!
Monal S: This is division, actual division. This is division, and it does the floor. It is floor division. It will not have the precision.
Monal S: This one will have the precision.
Monal S: This double will not have the precision, but only the point before the decimal.
Monal S: Guys… If you don't do your homework, what can I do for you?
Monal S: 0.3 gives 3. A divided by 0.3 gives D. What is the value of A?
Monal S: Man… If A is 3, and I divide by 0.3,
Monal S: What is the value which we are getting? Sorry, this is A.
Monal S: I have changed the value of A. Whatever the value of A is, now if I run it, it will not get. We are getting 10.
Monal S: If you're getting 10,
Monal S: It means it was 30 before. I changed the value. But it is the same thing, guys, it is the same thing. Now you have changed the notes which I've created.
Monal S: Okay, let me run it again.
Monal S: And you will understand. It was 6.66
Monal S: But when I do double slash, it is now 6.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Everything will work, guys. You are doing something weird. I trust Python more than everyone's queries, so I know it will work. You are doing something weird, I will help you later. Next is logical.
Monal S: logical operators.
Monal S: Okay, how many of you remember Logic Table? At least, how many of you have heard about truth table?
Monal S: Truth table. How many of you have heard? Non-tech people, I'm asking? How many of you have heard truth table?
Monal S: Not heard, not heard, great. It's fine. Okay?
Monal S: So…
Monal S: This is something which you guys need to kind of remember, alright? If you don't know, you can revise it in your free time, but this is… this will set the base of
Monal S: Okay. In electronics, in electronics, we have something called as logic gates.
Monal S: Just giving you a little bit of,
Monal S: background on this, okay? In electronics, we have something called as logic gate.
Monal S: Because I told you that electricity on is 1, electricity off is 0, if we only have electricity on or off, just like a switch in our homes, just like a switch in our homes, we can only do on and off.
Monal S: But our computers, which also works on electricity, does not just have on and off. They use this more complex way to provide you answer.
Monal S: And there comes logic gates, okay? Logic gate is a way to control your electricity in such a way that you can create more logic.
Monal S: Alright, you can create more logic. Logic means, if I have one, I want 0. What is the logic behind this? Everyone tell me, if the input is 1, I want 0. What is the logic?
Monal S: What is the logic? In Python, we have just seen naught, Nord means… Oppose it, Yes?
Monal S: What do we call this? This is… we will call it as a logic. Similarly, NOT is one of the logic. We have multiples of this logic to control the electricity in a way. The more we are able to control, it means the more we have flexibility to control our hardware just from Python itself.
Monal S: So what we will do, we will have truth table, which tells us the behavior of on and off.
Monal S: and the final output. What we should do with this on and off, alright? You will understand now.
Monal S: So, the first truth table, which we'll be learning is called as ANDGATE.
Monal S: Okay, and git. So let me first draw these things.
Monal S: Peter…
Monal S: This is better. Alright.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: So, first of all, I'm asking, if I have two values, A, and B.
Monal S: A and B.
Monal S: A can have two values.
Monal S: B can have two values. Tell me all the possible combinations of 2, all the possible combinations of two. How many combinations we can create?
Monal S: Maximum number we can have in a combination, just like 00 is a combination. It has two total lengths. How many total possible combinations we can create?
Monal S: Everyone!
Monal S: One combination is 0, 0.
Monal S: Another combination is 1-1. Another combination is 0, 1, another combination is 1-0. Can we create more than this?
Monal S: Can we create more than this?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: So now that we have all the possible combination, now we will talk about the operator. Which operator we are currently learning. The first operator we are learning is AND, okay? Now I will talk about how do we read AND operator. How do we read AND operator?
Monal S: So, AND means… Produces true when…
Monal S: Produces true when both are true.
Monal S: Guys, true in Python also means…
Monal S: True in Python also means 1.
Monal S: Answer, it gives you true when both are true, else it is… the answer is false.
Monal S: False means zero.
Monal S: Pulse is 0. Now read this.
Monal S: Bell, are both of them true?
Monal S: Are both of them true?
Monal S: Both of them are true? No. What should be the answer? What should be the answer?
Monal S: False. Guys, if both of them are not true, and says it is false. Zero.
Monal S: Are both of them true?
Monal S: Are both of them true? Yes. Are both of them true? No. Are both of them true? No. Only one of them is true here.
Monal S: Only one of them is true. This is what AND says. AND says only when both of them are same.
Monal S: Then it is true.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: Pulkit is saying wrong. Pulkit, what is wrong? Tell me.
Monal S: Enlighten me, Pulkit.
Monal S: Polkit is saying this is R.
Monal S: Bool kit.
Monal S: How confident you are, ma'am?
Monal S: Polkit, I will show you.
Monal S: Bulgate?
Monal S: This is from Real Digit.
Monal S: Pullkit?
Monal S: Are you clear, Polkad?
Monal S: Now you're not repeating 3 times? Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Monal S: See?
Monal S: It's fine.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: So, guys, and this is the main definition of AND. It's fine pool kit, okay?
Monal S: But sometimes what happens is that people act different, but you are not acting, so that is good.
Monal S: Next!
Monal S: Everyone, next.
Monal S: R.
Monal S: I'm talking about OR.
Monal S: Guys, I will talk about why I'm talking about Gates. I can ignore this gates concept, but…
Monal S: you will not understand when we are going to use the Python gates. Python gates is a little different. OR. What OR tells you… everyone see the definition of OR.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: R is… If… If any… if anyone… is true.
Monal S: If anyone is true, The answer is true.
Monal S: Just wait, guys, okay?
Monal S: If anyone is true, answer is true.
Monal S: Else?
Monal S: As?
Monal S: False.
Monal S: Let's fill it. If any one of them is true, let's fill now.
Monal S: If any one of them is true, no. None of them have won. Answer is 0.
Monal S: Any of them have won? Yes.
Monal S: Any of them have won? Yes. Any of them have won? Yes.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Now, there is next operator. Once we… I cover the operator, Python operators is just, like, 2 minutes of work.
Monal S: Toter.
Monal S: Next one that we are covering is called as NOT. Everyone already know NOT?
Monal S: But NOT does not work with 2. NOT only works with… one variable.
Monal S: The work of not… and if you only have one variable, are you going to have four combinations?
Monal S: If we have one variable, are we going to have four combinations? No, only 0 and 1 possibilities there, so I will remove this.
Monal S: What not tells you?
Monal S: Nought is, if the answer is true, Provide the opposite.
Monal S: If the answer is false, provide the opposite.
Monal S: Let's fill the naught, 0 will 1, 1 will be 0.
Monal S: Are we clear? Very simple.
Monal S: So we have covered what we'll be using in Python a lot.
Monal S: AND, OR, and NOT.
Monal S: Clear. So now, let me show you what is… please, okay, you guys want Zorb? Okay. Guys, there is one operator which is very popular, but in Python, I have never personally used Zorb, okay? But just for…
Monal S: you guys understanding, I will select ZOT. I don't want to write a lot of things, so I will copy the OR, which is all four combinations.
Monal S: Paste it here.
Monal S: And let's learn Zorp.
Monal S: So guys, in Zor, ZOR, we already seen that it is OR.
Monal S: Yes, you can already see it as all. Now, let me write what is the meaning of this.
Monal S: ZOR is another operator, which is… Only true.
Monal S: only true… Then… One of them… is true.
Monal S: Only when one of them is true.
Monal S: It is not saying both of them. Anshul, can you please let me teach this Zorb?
Monal S: If possible, Anshu.
Monal S: Then I will repeat N.
Monal S: Can I please request that from you?
Monal S: Guys.
Monal S: In or, if any of them is true, the answer is true. It is any one of them. Here, when only
Monal S: One of them is true.
Monal S: Only one of them is true.
Monal S: In case of OR, if any of them has 1, the answer is 1. Here, if only if one of them is true. See this?
Monal S: See, this is very important, now you will understand.
Monal S: It has one small difference as compared to your org.
Monal S: Tell me if any of them is one?
Monal S: Any of them is one? No.
Monal S: Here, we have both of them as one.
Monal S: Answer is 0. Here we have only one of them is 1.
Monal S: Only one of them is one.
Monal S: Ravi, this is what I've written, right?
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: It is ZOR or XOR.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So guys, just for a small recap, and I'm not going to repeat this, and is, it is true when both of them are true.
Monal S: It is true when both of them are true. Only both of them are true.
Monal S: We will get this.
Monal S: Or is, when any of them is true.
Monal S: When any of them is true.
Monal S: Yeah, Surya. You need to assign it, then it'll work.
Monal S: Any of them is true, it will work.
Monal S: NOT is opposite of what the value is, it only works with one variable, and ZOR is if
Monal S: only one of them is true, it will work. Guys, I'm just giving you a way to learn it easily. You can check notebooks, you can check the actual,
Monal S: books to get the real definition, but I just want to make your work simple.
Monal S: Not is a bit confusing, what is not? 0 is 1, 0 is 1, 1 is 0, that's all.
Monal S: So now, let's do the practical.
Monal S: Everyone, now let's do the practical, and in Python, it is very, very, very simple.
Monal S: How many of you think that it is simple?
Monal S: Guys… How many of you think that this is simple?
Monal S: So, this works with true and false. So, let me write, here, let's say, bool A. It means it is a variable called as A, but it is a type bool.
Monal S: It is true.
Monal S: And here we have rule of B.
Monal S: Here we have bool of B. I will say it as false.
Monal S: Alright? True and false. So, I have two variables. Now, what we will do… Bull A, and…
Monal S: Boole B. Duvino and Does everyone here knows, and…
Monal S: It means 1 and 0. What is 1 and 0?
Monal S: What is 1 or 0?
Monal S: What is… What is NOT 0?
Monal S: Bull B is 0, right? Bull B is false. What is NOT 0? Naught 0 is 1.
Monal S: What is not one?
Monal S: Is everyone clear? Now I will tell you how to read all of this.
Monal S: Alright? How to read all of this, okay? Now let's create a statement, and then we will write the code for it.
Monal S: Here, I'm saying that… If a person… okay.
Monal S: Club… Entry conditions.
Monal S: Okay? Club entry conditions.
Monal S: First condition, we will write it as…
Monal S: Person should be over 18.
Monal S: Second is… person… should have… at least…
Monal S: 500 in your local currency, alright? 500, I'm going to write INR. INR is Indian currency, alright? Person should have at least 500 INR to enter in club.
Monal S: Is this fine? So, here we have two conditions. It means both of them should be true. Are we clear?
Monal S: Both of them should be true. Only then we will let them enter.
Monal S: Only then we will let them enter. Tell me what we should use here.
Monal S: Tell me what we should use here.
Monal S: There is only one operator which tells you when both of them is true, we will let them enter.
Monal S: So, here I will write… Person Age.
Monal S: Alright, here I will write person age, Person age is, let's suppose, 20.
Monal S: But what is the person threshold?
Monal S: What is the person threshold which we have defined? Tell me… 18.
Monal S: Now let's talk about… Minimum… Balance they should have.
Monal S: We have defined 500. This is… Person Balance.
Monal S: Let's suppose it is Henrid.
Monal S: Just giving an example. So this is, now that we have 4 values, now, see, this is how we should write.
Monal S: I will write, First is…
Monal S: Person thread… person age… Should be greater than or equals to person threshold.
Monal S: Does it satisfies this one, everyone?
Monal S: Is this line satisfying the first condition?
Monal S: So, let's close with bracket. Bracket, when Python sees, it will solve everything in the bracket, and it will replace by value, alright? It is not something magical. We are just enclosing inside bracket, just like we do in our calculator.
Monal S: Alright, what is the next one?
Monal S: What is the next one we should use?
Monal S: If person balance is greater than or equal to minimum balance, then this satisfies the second condition.
Monal S: Guess?
Monal S: What we want between these two?
Monal S: We want to check both of them to be true, so can I write AND and this condition? This will give you an answer in true and false. This will give you answer in true and false.
Monal S: True and false, true and false will give you AND operation. Yes?
Monal S: If I do print, I've enclosed this whole inner thing inside a print.
Monal S: So this all will be replaced by the final true or false. We will just print it, so let's see.
Monal S: False. Why?
Monal S: Because we can see person age is 20, but person balance is 100. If I make it 600, will it make both the condition as true?
Monal S: Person age is already correct. Now, person balance is also correct. Let's see.
Monal S: Is it working? Is everyone able to create the logic?
Monal S: Are we able to understand logical operators? Very simple.
Monal S: As I'm an electrical engineer, it is more, understandable to me. That's great, guys. That's great. Very simple. So, guys, see, in day one, we started storing things. Now, we are storing things, but creating our own logic, that is what developers is.
Monal S: We create our own logic. So this is how you should think. Everything is at the end storage, but what you will do with the storage, create logic from it using Python languages, this is operator, this is another operator, and create the final thing.
Monal S: Simple. Everyone is enjoying today's class.
Monal S: Guys, are you enjoying today's class? Is it hard?
Monal S: Is it hard?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: And everyone, do you like the way we are writing these folder structures?
Monal S: Easy to maintain. See, in the initial classes, you might feel it… feel like it is a lot of work, we need to maintain this. But as you move forward, if you create this structure, it is very organized.
Monal S: In the initial phases, it might feel chaotic, but it is very organized.
Monal S: So, if I'm teaching something, it feels complex, trust me, it is for your own good.
Monal S: Alright? So guys, it is already 10.32, just give me a second, alright? I just need to make a one call. If…
Monal S: Mentor is available, I will check one thing. Just need to check one thing.
Monal S: Guys, ZOR is directly not available in Python, but I was just teaching ZOR because people want it. We don't need ZOR here, in our case.
Monal S: All right? Thank you very much, guys, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, the one which I was talking about. Guys, your screen is not frozen, I was not doing anything, alright? I was just checking with someone, but maybe we will do that later.
Monal S: Okay, so it is 10.33 here, good time to give break, but 15 minutes is more than enough, right? So after break, what is our goal? Let's, again, go back to where we were.
Monal S: We have… we are done with operators.
Monal S: Alright, we are done with operators, now we will go to…
Monal S: But now we will go to Control Flow.
Monal S: Control flow is also a very simple, but very powerful part.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: And, do you guys want to know? Guys, Bitwise, I never use.
Monal S: If you want to learn bitwise, I will tell you bitwise.
Monal S: How many of you want to learn bitwise?
Monal S: Alright? So, after Bitwise, can I give break?
Monal S: After Bitwise, it will not take long.
Monal S: Very simple.
Monal S: Say this, I'm not going to bitwise because it, again, I need to tell the fundamentals, alright? But, yeah, let me tell the fundamentals. Where is it? Everyone say this.
Monal S: I'm okay to skip few things, but if it is not useful… I've never used Bitwise, right?
Monal S: There are use cases, but again, in competitive programming and other places.
Monal S: Okay? So I will tell you,
Monal S: When we work with bit, I told you that computers don't understand 1, 2, 3, 4. Our CPU does not understand 1, 2, 3, 4. Our CPU understands
Monal S: Our CPU understand what language, binary language, numbers are language which consists of only 0 and 1, alright? And anything can be written in 0 and 1, and there is a way to do it. This is how we should do. 1, 2, 4.
Monal S: 1, 2, 4. Tell me, if I add this number, what is the total we will get?
Monal S: If I add this number, what is the total we will get?
Monal S: This works like 2 to the power of 0, 2 to the power of 1, 2 to the power of 2, 2 to the power of 3, whatever the number is, we write it here, alright? But I'm only going to write here, just for making you understand, 2 to the power of 2, which is 4.
Monal S: The final output, the total which we can get is 7. So it means we can write 1 to 7 using 4 to 1 as the stage. Suppose this is our stage.
Monal S: Now, let's write one. Let's write one.
Monal S: It should only consist of 0 and 1. So if I need to write 1, which combinations I should use to write 1?
Monal S: The first one. Other should be 0.
Monal S: So, 1, when we have a three-stage binary, will be 001. So, 001 is called as 1. If I talk about 2, which combinations I can use to write 2?
Monal S: The middle one, 010, because this is 2. Let's talk about 3.
Monal S: which combinations I should use, which will make the total sum as 3.
Monal S: Total sum is 3.
Monal S: If I make this, this is 4. If I make this, this is 2. I still need 1 more 1.
Monal S: So, 2 plus 1, that is this one, will make it 3.
Monal S: This is by 3 in binary. If I talk about 4, 4 is this one.
Monal S: If I talk about the last number, 7, 7 means…
Monal S: 4 plus 2 plus 1. This will give you 7.
Monal S: Are we able to create 1 to 7? Will we be able to create whole 1 to 7 using this system? Yes? Alright.
Monal S: So, bitwise operators in Python, we have something like as AND
Monal S: OR and NOT. Similarly, which we did, but this is the symbol which we will be using.
Monal S: It is the same like a logical operator, but instead of working with numbers, We work with binary.
Monal S: We work with binary. And now, let's see it. Everyone knows AND or NOT?
Monal S: Everyone knows AND or NOT.
Monal S: Yes, now we will see. Let's suppose I want to work with a number of 3.
Monal S: Just wait, okay? Again, just wait.
Monal S: Okay, so you guys will get surprised. So, let's do for 3 and 1. Where is 3? This is 3. We are selecting 3 and 1 for operation.
Monal S: So we will select this, we will select this. So let me write first 3.
Monal S: Where is our 3?
Monal S: 011. This is our 3. Now, I want to do… 1.
Monal S: 1 is 0, 0, 1.
Monal S: If I perform AND operation, AND means when both of them is 1, it will return 1.
Monal S: Is both of them one?
Monal S: Answer is 0. Is both of them 1? Answer is 0. What is the final answer we are getting?
Monal S: What this value is?
Monal S: 001 is 1. So when we do binary 3 and binary 1, when we perform AND operation, we get 1 as the answer.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: So, it is on bitwise level. Are we clear, everyone?
Monal S: Similarly, 011 and 001. Let's perform OR operation. This one is OR.
Monal S: OR means, if any of them has 1, answer is 1.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So, this will be 011. 011 is… 011 is 3.
Monal S: So, 3 or 1 will gives you… see, I'm writing, 3, 1, performing the operation of OR will give you 3.
Monal S: NOT. NOT works on opposite.
Monal S: NOT again will work on only one number. If I do NOT of 3,
Monal S: If I do NOT of the… this is how we write NOT.
Monal S: Naught of 3 will be?
Monal S: 0 will give you 1, 1 will give you 0, 1 will give you 0.
Monal S: What is the answer?
Monal S: Fourth.
Monal S: Naught of 3 gave you 4.
Monal S: Are we clear, everyone?
Monal S: Alright? So, if you want to see this, I will show you.
Monal S: In Python, we don't have to write binary, but we can write something like if a… okay, let me write logic,
Monal S: No. Carrot here is not.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: what exactly we are doing? We are doing bitwise operator. Sometimes even I get confused with the topics.
Monal S: bitwise operators.
Monal S: We will again work with 3 and 1, so that we know exactly what is the answer. B is equals to 1, alright? So let's do print
Monal S: print A, single and, and B.
Monal S: Same thing.
Monal S: Were we able to do the same thing, yes or no?
Monal S: Guys, yes or no?
Monal S: Guys, I'm only teaching you fundamentals because we don't have to waste time here, alright?
Monal S: This is… or… Same thing.
Monal S: Working, Now, this one, I need to do what?
Monal S: Okay, wait, wait.
Monal S: I gave you OR and AND, but this one is not, sorry. The symbol I messed up. Someone was wrong. The symbol of this one is tilde.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Distilled data that we see is not.
Monal S: Alright? This one is Zor. Let me write it correctly.
Monal S: Are we clear now?
Monal S: This one is not.
Monal S: So, if you have to write NOT, Notice, Thus, let me write it.
Monal S: Yep.
Monal S: It goes before.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: It gives you… why it is giving us… Negative here.
Monal S: Just give me a second, okay?
Monal S: It gives you the complement.
Monal S: But I'm just checking… that…
Monal S: No, guys, A was… 3.
Monal S: No, no, no, this is not only. I'm just looking that…
Monal S: When maybe some sign changes happens when we do not.
Monal S: Inverting 00 results in that one.
Monal S: Wait, wait, yeah, yeah, yes, yes, it is 3.
Monal S: it becomes 1, so it is negative. Yes, guys, there is a sign bit also that happens, so sine is also converting. Because it was positive, the sign is also doing the positive, okay? So it inverts all the bits.
Monal S: Because the sign also has a number. Are we clear?
Monal S: When we do this, the sign internally also has a bit.
Monal S: It also flips the sign, that's why we are getting negative.
Monal S: But we have seen 4, 4 was correct. Guys, 4 was correct.
Monal S: But it also flips the sign.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So, for all of this, we have to go into the bit level and understand it. So, that's why I'm not teaching, because, see, I will teach you one… I will show… I don't have that example, but I have seen one very good example of this gates, these bitwise operators. Someone used it in competitive programming.
Monal S: they performed some bitwise operation of something to find some missing value, and they were able to do it. So it is used in some edge cases, but you, me, someone who is not using that, is never going to use this bitwise.
Monal S: Alright? It's never going to use this bitwise.
Monal S: Guys, for 3, we did the bitwise of 4. Because it is positive, it also flipped the number.
Monal S: Alright? It also flips the number, and then we get the negative.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So, this one is done. Guys, ZOR you can also do, if I have to do each and everything.
Monal S: What do you guys have to do for Zorp?
Monal S: I'm not going to solve it manually, but you guys can solve it. Where is this? This is all.
Monal S: Okay? Everyone knows how to solve ZOR. Guys, this is something unnecessary which we are doing, but everyone knows how to solve ZOR.
Monal S: How many of you here does not know how to solve XOR?
Monal S: Yes, Ashish, actually, it adds one.
Monal S: While converting for the decimal, To decimal value, it converts its add plus 1 also.
Monal S: But I'm not going into the depth.
Monal S: Got it? Otherwise, people will get confused.
Monal S: Alright? So, this is done.
Monal S: Now that the logical part is done, anyone has any question on this logic… bitwise operator?
Monal S: Anyone?
Monal S: Guys, Bitwise, anyone?
Monal S: Yes, Pradeep, it inverts it at once to convert into the decimal, but again, it adds some more steps. I don't want people to get confused.
Monal S: Pradeep, yes, it inverts all the values, add one to convert into decimal, then it does the switching of negative, plus to negative, negative to plus.
Monal S: Can we print output in binary? Guys, there are functions which does it. Let me just show you. Decimal to binary in Python. I don't really use it, that's why I'm also looking at it, but I've seen it before, okay? So, yes, you have something called as bin.
Monal S: For a number, if A is equals to 30, if you want to convert that to a binary, you just pass to a function of bin, and pass the number. It gives you binary.
Monal S: Binary of that number.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: If you want to see that binary, we will see that slicing again.
Monal S: Guys, we don't… we rarely use it, and me, personally, I have never used it. So let's not waste time here, okay? Because it is a part of the syllabus I'm teaching you.
Monal S: So we are able to complete our whole operators.
Monal S: Anura, right now, we are not at that stage.
Monal S: Guys, how many of you, as a child, when you were learning A, B, C, D, ask that what I'm going to do with that A, B, C, D?
Monal S: Currently, we are in AVCD of programming. We are understanding the power of program once we understand it. I told you.
Monal S: We learned ABCD, but we combined ABCD to create something bigger. Similarly, right now, we are using Bitwise and others, which is not at all useful in our data science job, alright? It is a part of Python. Whatever is part of useful, I will teach you examples, but this one is not at all required.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand? You don't need to connect dots which you don't require.
Monal S: Yes, Sumit?
Monal S: Alright, so this one is done. Now let's go on break.
Monal S: Again, people are in bitwise shift. Guys, we can do anything. Why do you want to do it? Can't you?
Monal S: Just… check it.
Monal S: So let me share the ti- let me…
Monal S: Share the screen of the timer.
Monal S: And then let's move forward.
Monal S: Guys, you can skip bitwise, but I already taught you bitwise, so don't worry. So, I'm starting the timer, I will see you after break, okay?
Monal S: See you guys, bye-bye.
Mayank Aggarwal: Perfect.
Mayank Aggarwal: Hey, hi everyone. Very good morning.
Mayank Aggarwal: Change of mentors in between.
Mayank Aggarwal: Administer.
Mayank Aggarwal: I think the mic can be changed.
Mayank Aggarwal: Hi, hi everyone, Extreme Dish.
Mayank Aggarwal: Thankful request as epne kara. Sorry, extremely, I will do that.
Mayank Aggarwal: Or else you can send me your link off LinkedIn, I will do the same.
Mayank Aggarwal: Chica.
Mayank Aggarwal: Great, great, great. So I hope all of you are having fun while learning, right?
Mayank Aggarwal: All of you are having fun while learning. Have you been following your IDK series? Yes, thanks a lot for that. Rohit, I will be putting a pipe short for that, don't worry. So, no problem.
Mayank Aggarwal: Cool, everyone. So… Just a minute…
Mayank Aggarwal: Some funny thing, yeah, cool.
Mayank Aggarwal: Great.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, yeah. Actually, everyone, I just wanted to share a few more things with all of you, as I promised. So, regarding the course. I will accept the request, everyone, don't worry. Extremely sorry, actually, as you all know, we are kind of working on some
Mayank Aggarwal: more things with respect to launch, right? So, yes, everyone now, this is actually one more course which we would like to provide you. Now, again, the course is hot and new, it is a bestseller, like, lots of people have taken it already.
Mayank Aggarwal: Good ratings.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: Again, I will tell you the idea, so…
Mayank Aggarwal: since you all are now learning from scratch, parallelly, it is not something which we can wait, right? So, the whole thing is that, everyone, we have to make sure that, parallelly, for people who are not aware.
Mayank Aggarwal: you are able to understand AI as well, right?
Mayank Aggarwal: We don't want that, okay, one year after, when maybe things can change, you all are having no idea about AI. And again, I think that will happen in next 5-6 months only, because you are in this course.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, again, around this, around this agreement, what I'm providing you today is a course in which we have explained all about
Mayank Aggarwal: AI with NHN, so if you will see, AI Automation and Agentic AI Bootcamp. In this, actually, we have discussed about what is multi-agent architecture, MCP, RAG, and the best part is, again, nothing is with code, okay? So, yeah, I'm pasting the link in the chat, everyone. I hope all of you know how to use it.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, just pasting the link.
Mayank Aggarwal: I will shorten the link as well, so do make sure that you…
Mayank Aggarwal: take benefit of that. And yes, just like last time, it will be really helpful if you can go and provide a good rating for the course. So, if you all remember last time.
Mayank Aggarwal: And I ask so that it reaches out to the maximum people. It's free, everyone, totally free, and there's a reason for this, giving this particular course. So, course coupon, okay, just let me share the link.
Mayank Aggarwal: Just a minute, everyone, link shortener.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, just a minute, I will quickly share the links with all of you.
Mayank Aggarwal: Yeah.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, yes, everyone, please go through the same. If you will see, again, please make sure that once you get access, how many people are able to get the access?
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay, my bad.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, again, it will be totally free with the coupon I'm sharing.
Mayank Aggarwal: Apply the coupon, everyone. Let me check…
Mayank Aggarwal: Quickly, I think it should be free. Let me open it in Gognito.
Mayank Aggarwal: And then I will just take your… this much time.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay, let me quickly check, everyone, extremely sorry.
Mayank Aggarwal: Why it is showing 399?
Mayank Aggarwal: Actually, I did ask you, Demi, to provide me with a coupon, but just one minute, okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: Don't pay, okay? I'll be providing you with the free coupon.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, the reason between behind both these courses, everyone, is… Okay, yeah. So, pay attention, everyone, this is the one. Sorry, my bad. Yeah, I gave the wrong code.
Mayank Aggarwal: My bad.
Mayank Aggarwal: The one which I have given you, I think this is something which you can use.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay? So, just go to this course and apply Learn AI instead, Learn AI.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, this is the Kubernet device they gave me.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay? It will be then totally free, and as you can see, just one day is left at this price, everyone. And once you get the access, again, will be really helpful if you can go and just give a good rating. So, once you start learning.
Mayank Aggarwal: please go and leave a rating, and please make sure that it is 5-star. And also, please, please make sure that you take the benefit of this course, because as I told.
Mayank Aggarwal: We don't want that you are not aware about AI, and in this course specifically, we have explained about AI in depth. So the difference between this course and the last one which I shared is that this course helps you to understand about AI
Mayank Aggarwal: NATN and everything from scratch. Then, the next course, right, everyone? It can help you to start your agency with that. So, basically, starting and providing services with that. So, that's the whole plan, okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: Here's data engineering, which I am planning for that, don't worry, okay? So, Learn AI is the coupon, everyone. Go with this one first.
Mayank Aggarwal: Go with this one first, and then the next one, okay? So this Learn AI is the coupon.
Mayank Aggarwal: Please make sure that you apply it. I think people will be able to do that.
Mayank Aggarwal: Right?
Mayank Aggarwal: It should be working, pretty sure it should be working.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, learn AI, just one… it is just left for one day, so please, please make sure that you take, benefit of that. Along with that, as I said, will be really helpful if you leave a rating, and again, you can see that how the course is bestseller, highest rated, and everything.
Mayank Aggarwal: It is generally one of the best courses out there, okay? Please see this, please see this, and then go to the agency one. Here, I've explained everything without even a pinch of code, so no code at all.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay? AI in automation, agents, what are agents? Okay, so all of these things, I have explained in very easy manner.
Mayank Aggarwal: So… If you just, let's say, go to my learnings, And let's hit this one.
Mayank Aggarwal: All of those things are present, okay? So… See? Agents? What are agents?
Mayank Aggarwal: It is for beginners, yes. It is totally for beginners. The courses which I'm providing all of you, that is totally, totally for beginners, okay? There is one more course which I'm planning, which I'm trying to get access to, that is around the TSA one.
Mayank Aggarwal: So I will try and give that to my guest in the next class, okay? As you promised, because all of these are very, very basic courses. Now, once you start the course, everyone, go to RAG Bootcamp.
Mayank Aggarwal: And then you can leave, like, sorry, just any codes, and you can leave a rating like this.
Mayank Aggarwal: So make sure that you go, and also make sure that you do the course, okay? Please, please make sure that you do it.
Mayank Aggarwal: And yeah, that would be helpful. And again, please make sure that you take the benefit every when it's one day left at this price. First, do this course, and then the next one.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, each and everything?
Mayank Aggarwal: With respect to AI is covered, I'm just trying for one more course, which I will let you know, I think I will provide… get the access to this next week.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, yes, this is the One Everyone, which is, again, a bestseller.
Mayank Aggarwal: As you can see. But I don't have free coupon as of now, and I don't want to spend money. Because this is also an advanced course, 33,000 people.
Mayank Aggarwal: Best seller?
Mayank Aggarwal: So, yeah, I think that was all the women. If anyone has anything, you can let us know. Please, please leave a rating. In that way, it will be very, very helpful. Please make sure that you complete today's course first, and then you go to the next one, which I shared last time.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay.
Mayank Aggarwal: Cool. Raghman, it was a couple good? No, no, again, we try, A, that we can get access, so that is not in our hand properly. Second is that, anyway, that's not a course from scratch, okay? So the course which I'm sharing, that is from scratch.
Mayank Aggarwal: Please go… I'm sharing the shortened link as well, and you should be able to get access. Please make sure that once you get access, you leave a very good rating, so that it can reach out to maximum people. As of now, the coupon code is valid. I could see that people are able to get it.
Mayank Aggarwal: And yeah, I think that was all, which I wanted to just quickly share with all of you, so thanks a lot. And yes, just one day left, everyone, so please, please, please make sure that you take it, because once it expires, then we will not be able to provide it again.
Mayank Aggarwal: Even this time as well, I have to reach out to Udemy and ask the same, so yeah, that will be the case.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay, good idea.
Mayank Aggarwal: Cool.
Mayank Aggarwal: And do make sure that you do with this. NATN is an awesome framework. There is a reason I'm teaching these things with NATN. It's totally no good. So each and every one of you, even if you're in school, you can access the same.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay? Free access, no worries.
Mayank Aggarwal: First editing coupon has expired, yes. That's why I ask you, just take it as soon as you get it.
Mayank Aggarwal: Okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: Great.
Mayank Aggarwal: Cello. Cool then, everyone, I think I will leave you.
Mayank Aggarwal: With that, thanks a lot, Munal, sir. I think we can get back the permission. And everyone, please, once you get this, please leave a rating.
Mayank Aggarwal: Please make sure that you leave a 5-star rating on the course. The same will be very, very helpful for reaching out to other people. So, yes, hardly I think it will take that. Can we get access to the course after one day? One day excess means that this free coupon is valid for Monday, okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: This free coupon is valid for one day. Access, you have lifetime.
Mayank Aggarwal: Code is Learn AI. The easiest code I think there will be. Learn AI. So do it parallelly with your bootcamp, you can… you should be fine with that, okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: Total.
Mayank Aggarwal: So, and also make sure that you do the course as well. It is very, very important.
Mayank Aggarwal: Dsa, when I'm trying, everyone, I will try, that if I get the access, I will provide it next time, because that's also very, very important.
Mayank Aggarwal: And many people might be needing that, so yes, okay? Don't worry, all the courses which we try, we get access, we will try to give you as soon as we are able to get it. Meanwhile, yeah, please just make sure that you leave a rating so that it can reach out to maximum people, okay? We have to actually
Mayank Aggarwal: connect with you, Demi, get the coupon, like, it's a pretty long process. That's why I'm planning for TSA as well, like, though it's an established course, I still want that we are able to take the benefit of that, and you all can take the benefit of that, okay?
Mayank Aggarwal: I'll show you. Cool.
Mayank Aggarwal: Thanks a lot, Monaster. I think I let me provide the excess of host.
Monal S: So we don't…
Mayank Aggarwal: What's the last minute.
Mayank Aggarwal: Yes, I think I made the host. Maybe just see the course as well for some time, and you will get the rating option, okay? Please do that.
Monal S: Right, yes, thank you very much, Mangsar and guys.
Monal S: If the rating is not visible to you right now, after you watch a few lectures, you will be able to see the rating. UDMA will automatically ask you to provide the rating, alright?
Monal S: And,
Monal S: We will be sharing… we can also share the link, yes. Guys, we can also share the link in the community later, okay? Whoever has access to that, they will be able to access it. So I've copied the link, and after the class is over, I will provide that link, all right?
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Everyone happy?
Monal S: Everyone happy with courses, free courses, amazing courses?
Monal S: Happy? Great. All right, awesome, guys. Don't worry, we'll tell you when to… which to pick one, what you should do with multiple courses and other things, alright?
Monal S: Okay, so let's get started. Where were we? And let me remove my headphone, because I don't require it right now.
Monal S: I was not able to even hear myself correctly.
Monal S: Okay, so this is where we were. I hope everyone is… guys, please come back here. I know everyone is excited, everyone wants to learn a lot of new things, but I want you here.
Monal S: Yes? Okay. So, we have… we are done with string properties, we are done with operators. Operators is finally over, we have seen all the examples. Now we will start with control flow, alright? So, let me…
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Guys, let's talk about things later, okay?
Monal S: We cannot extend every class for 6 hours.
Monal S: True?
Monal S: Control Flow.
Monal S: Great, guys, great. Don't worry, you will get access.
Monal S: So, let me give you a little bit of introduction about control flow.
Monal S: Just read.
Monal S: So, control flow is the concept, it comes with certain code, and those statements, those code statements, helps control the flow of the program, alright? So, using control flow, what we do? Using control flow, we control the
Monal S: Flow of the program.
Monal S: Alright? So right now, we have seen that the flow goes from top to bottom, right? This is the current flow.
Monal S: whatever is there, line by line, we need to execute it. There is no option to not execute certain line, there is no option to skip certain line, or create a flow from it, alright? There is no option right now.
Monal S: How many of you think that there is option? We have learned certain commands that gives us option? No. Till now, we haven't.
Monal S: So, using control flow, what we require, we want to con… we want the control that currently I'm here, I want to execute these three lines, then I want to check certain things based on my condition.
Monal S: And if that does not satisfies, I can also skip that step, skip steps, whatever steps I want, and I will be able to execute in, again, top to bottom, but I have a control of what statements to run, what statements not to run.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Guys?
Monal S: So, it is used…
Monal S: to execute… everyone know what is execute? Execute and run is the same thing. It is used to execute or run
Monal S: blocks of code, Blocks of code on a specific conditions.
Monal S: Alright, specific conditions.
Monal S: Now, let me talk about what are the components of this control statement. It is very human, interpretable language, it is very easy to understand. So, let's suppose I'm giving you a simple task. This is your task. You don't have to do coding. Task means we will just discuss this task.
Monal S: So this is a task we…
Monal S: Okay, our requirement is we need to buy
Monal S: 4 apples, okay? We need to buy 4 apples is our requirement. So, first thing what we will do, the first thing which we will do, we will check if
Monal S: Apple is greater than or equals to 4, yes?
Monal S: This is how we do a check in real world. We will check first whether 4 apples are present in the store or not. Yes, guys, we checked this one. What we will check?
Monal S: weather… 4 apples… or more… are present… in the store.
Monal S: If 4 apples are not present, what we will do?
Monal S: 84 apples are not present, what we will do?
Monal S: We will not buy the apple. This is, suppose, whatever condition is.
Monal S: Only if apples are present in the store, We will buy apples.
Monal S: But if 4 apples are not present in the store, then we will do what?
Monal S: Then we will do what? So this is like, if 4 apples Then…
Monal S: If this condition is not correct, then we will do something else. That means we will… Not… by Apple.
Monal S: Yes, this is how we make decisions in real world.
Monal S: Guys, tell me!
Monal S: Tell me if this is how we do decision in real world or not.
Monal S: Yes, everyone does it in the real world every day. Do you have some person's number? Is it available? What food it is? If it is not your liking, you might not eat it, or you might order online. Everything is based on, if it is available, then we will do this. If not, then I will do something else.
Monal S: Similarly, In Python, we have something called as if and else.
Monal S: Here, we have if and else. Here, in IF, we write the condition we want.
Monal S: Here, we write the condition. If certain condition, then we do something else.
Monal S: Then, if the condition satisfies, then we will do this.
Monal S: If the condition does not satisfy, only then we will go and do something which is written in the else spot.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: to see what I'm… how I'm going to write this in our notebook. So what we are doing…
Monal S: Guys, it is very simple. If and else. Only one of them runs at a time. So here, we are running…
Monal S: Conditional statements. We write it conditional statements, or…
Monal S: Control flow. Conditional statements is a part of control flow. Control flow is kind of a generic term, but technically we call those as
Monal S: conditional statements, alright? This is the main technical Python language. Conditional statement. So let's say I want to check, if
Monal S: See this.
Monal S: The first I will write the problem statement as we want to give Access to Batch 1 recording.
Monal S: two people, Pull by… Batch, too.
Monal S: Yes, this is what you all are getting. So, currently, what we will say?
Monal S: our current batch.
Monal S: What is our current badge, guys?
Monal S: What is our current batch? 2. This is batch 2. Alright? So this one, we will say, if.
Monal S: the current batch is greater than. Either we can write greater than, either we can write equals, or we can write greater than and equals to, because for the batch 3, we will do the same. If we don't want to give the same to the batch 3, then we will write
Monal S: this.
Monal S: Are we able to understand when to use double equals to? Greater than at equals to, and double equals to? There is a difference.
Monal S: This one will only be active for batch 2, but if you want to give everyone who is greater than a request to batch 2, then I will be using this. But for now, only for batch 2. Then here, what I will do, I will write.
Monal S: Access to Ultimate Data Science Batch 1.0.
Monal S: also provided.
Monal S: If the student is not from batch 2, else does not have a condition, else is like, if it's not true, then what?
Monal S: Then what? Then we will say… You only have… Access to Badge 1.0.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand how the coding is going to flow?
Monal S: If has certain condition.
Monal S: If a certain condition, then we need to write the colon. Guys, this is called as colon, then we need to write the colon. Colon tells Python that whatever we are going to write after that.
Monal S: alright, is going to be the part of if… I will tell you the syntax, don't worry, I will tell you the syntax, but first understand the flow. Then we will talk about the syntax. But is everyone able to understand the high level, how the flow looks like?
Monal S: Only if this is true.
Monal S: Only if this is true, then this will happen. So, if you just write true as well, Python will work.
Monal S: If only requires true to be present here. Either you write true from some condition, or just write basic dummy true. If it is basic dummy true, else will never run. Why? Because only one of them runs at a time. Either if will run, either else will run. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Without colon, it will not work. Colon is the requirement. We'll talk about syntax, guys. So, if only requires true, when it is true, then it will work.
Monal S: But if it is false, then this will not work, else will work. So let me go back to the condition, and you guys will tell me if the condition is true or not. Tell me if the condition is true or not. Guys, I will repeat everything, don't worry. You will first see the execution, then I will show you the flow.
Monal S: Currently, this condition is true.
Monal S: So this one will work.
Monal S: So let's see… Are we getting the same thing?
Monal S: See this? Okay, something is wrong here. What is going on? Yes.
Monal S: It is working.
Monal S: Is it working?
Monal S: It is true.
Monal S: But if batch is equals to 3, then this one will be… this one will be false.
Monal S: When the current batch is 3, this one will be false. If this is false, we will not go and check this, we will go to the final thing.
Monal S: Batch is not 3, then do what? Then we will do this.
Monal S: Is it working?
Monal S: Are we able to control the flow?
Monal S: Yeah, first check it.
Monal S: Anuraq, check the arrow why it is wrong. You have written something wrong.
Monal S: Alright? So we are able to control the flow. Now let's talk about the syntax.
Monal S: Okay? This is not as simple… it is simple, but it is not as simple, but I want everyone's focus to be present here.
Monal S: This is what we call a syntax of something. We need to write the keyword of Python called as if.
Monal S: Then we provide some kind of a condition. Condition we can provide in bracket, it is also fine.
Monal S: This is condition. Then we need to write colon.
Monal S: Alright? Then we'll write colon. When you press enter, you will see that Python will not start from here. See this?
Monal S: If I mention something like, if true.
Monal S: After colon, if I press enter, it is not starting from here.
Monal S: This is automatic indentation Python is providing. Here, you will see, we need to start the code, whatever we want to do when the condition is true, we will write it here.
Monal S: If you start writing from here, Python will not consider it as a part of if.
Monal S: Are we clear? If we start writing from here, this line as the if, Python will not consider it as a part of if.
Monal S: it will consider it as a part of normal Python code, which we were doing till now.
Monal S: Are we clear? So, to make it as a block of if, a part of if, we provide this indentation. This empty space which we are getting is called as indentation.
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: This empty space that we have.
Monal S: This is nothing but… indentation.
Monal S: Are we clear, everyone?
Monal S: This space via clear.
Monal S: Okay, we can write 100 lines of code inside this block, that is also totally fine. Whatever you want to do when the condition is true, you can write it here like a normal Python. There is no constraint. But if you don't provide this colon, it will not work.
Monal S: Once all the… once this condition is true, if the condition is true, Python will execute all the lines of code present here, then it will look for what is the next line of code.
Monal S: Else!
Monal S: I will show you, okay? Else.
Monal S: And else will have its own block.
Monal S: ELSE does not have a condition because we have written the condition in the if block. After colon, again, we will see the indentation. It means whatever we are going to write here is a part of else block.
Monal S: So this is how the Python will work. I will show you, okay? See this code.
Monal S: Everyone, focus. Current batch is 3. Python will execute, save the 3 into the current batch.
Monal S: Next line, it is empty. Next line, it is a if block. It will check if the current batch is equals to… if this condition, this is a condition, if current batch is equals to 2, what is the answer of this?
Monal S: What is the answer of this?
Monal S: Tell me.
Monal S: 2 is equals to 2… 3 is equals to 2?
Monal S: Is 3 is equals to 2? No, it is false. So…
Monal S: So whenever if is failed, else will run.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand the flow?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand the flow? Very simple.
Monal S: Now comes a different part. See this?
Monal S: if can exist without the else as well, and you can write other part of code as well. Just similar, like, A is equals to 2, B is equal to 2, now you are doing print of A plus 4.
Monal S: What we are doing, we are just… we… here we have assigned the value of 3 to the variable. We are checking something. If this is false, Python will… first, is 3 equals to 2? False.
Monal S: Will Python go inside?
Monal S: Will Python go inside? No, Python is not going to go inside the if block. What is the next line of code? Empty. What is the next line of code? A equals to 2.
Monal S: It will keep on executing.
Monal S: Do we require else here in this case? We don't need else.
Monal S: But if is required.
Monal S: So if I run it, what I will see? I will not see access to UDS batch, I will just see 4, because it is this line of code.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Is everyone able to interpret the code?
Monal S: Everyone is able to interpret the code.
Monal S: Next!
Monal S: If I just write else.
Monal S: Else does not have a condition. Else means if something does not work, then do this.
Monal S: But if I don't even have the condition, it means then do this. How it is different from just simple print.
Monal S: So, else will not exist without a if block. You cannot have else. You can see we are getting error.
Monal S: Are you able to see error?
Monal S: Because if we only have else, how different it is from just writing simple print?
Monal S: Make sense?
Monal S: So, else… should exist only with IF.
Monal S: Else cannot exist without a if block.
Monal S: Guys, very straightforward.
Monal S: ELSE cannot exist without an IF. For else to work, you require if block. If certain kind of a condition, you will write just like this.
Monal S: If current batch is equals to 2.
Monal S: Then we will do something, let's print hello.
Monal S: Only print hello. Dummy thing.
Monal S: Now you can see error is gone.
Monal S: Now you can see error is gone. So what are acceptable ways to write block?
Monal S: You can write if… condition…
Monal S: and its block, and else, and its block. This is one way. Another way is, you can write a condition
Monal S: And then a block. This is another way. But you cannot write else alone, because it does not even make sense.
Monal S: So, these two are accepted.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Guys, tell me…
Monal S: In real world, you will ask a question that whether you have 4 apples, you need to buy 4 apples. The first thing is, you will check whether the store has 4 apples or not.
Monal S: In real world, will you directly not buy the apple when the requirement is apple?
Monal S: In real world, will you directly go to the end condition.
Monal S: I need to buy Apple, I will not buy Apple. Does it make sense? You never checked it.
Monal S: In real world, there needs to be a condition first, whether it is available or not. If I ask, if you guys ask me my email.
Monal S: The first thing is, I have to provide it. Avilu directly says, sir, I have your email.
Monal S: Can you say that?
Monal S: Sir, I have your email, without even asking.
Monal S: Does it make sense in real world? Similarly, in Python, if you're asking a question, sir, can we have else alone?
Monal S: Just think for a second, what does it even mean?
Monal S: Else does not even have a condition. If something does not have a condition, it will run always. If something run always, why not use the code directly? Why use else?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone able to relate?
Monal S: So, guys, indentation is nothing but tab, you can see.
Monal S: How many dots you're able to see here, tell me.
Monal S: How many dots you are able to see?
Monal S: In my code, 4 dots means 4 space.
Monal S: So, this is just like a py… your keyboard tab part. One tab is equals to four spaces.
Monal S: Either you press 1 tab, either you press 4 tab if Python does not provide. See this?
Monal S: Let's say I delete. If true.
Monal S: I have mentioned the colon, then pressed enter. This is already an indentation which my IDE VS code is providing. But if I delete this tab, I can either press Tab as a button, you can see tab in your keyboard, or you can press 1, 2, 3, 4, 4 tabs in order for it to work.
Monal S: Not… not colon, but print something. Print hello.
Monal S: See, right now I've written 4 spaces.
Monal S: Is it working? It's working.
Monal S: If I remove everything, press one tab, it's also working.
Monal S: It works with two spaces also.
Monal S: But don't always use two spaces, because that is not the standard. Indentation means Python just need a way to understand that which code belongs to the if block.
Monal S: If I remove all the space, how you're going to differentiate which belongs to Python, which belongs to your normal code like this?
Monal S: This is our normal code. How Python is going to understand that something belongs to the if block.
Monal S: Only with the help of indentation.
Monal S: So now Python know that if indentation is present, it means this print is a part of this condition.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Are we clear, everyone? I'm not going to repeat this.
Monal S: So, yes, you can write if without a else block, it is totally acceptable.
Monal S: It is totally acceptable.
Monal S: Okay, now I'm going to give you a condition, how to make things better, software development better, or user experience better.
Monal S: The task is…
Monal S: You, as a developer are creating an application
Monal S: You as a developer is creating an application or tool our tool, Which will help you
Monal S: connect to a Wi-Fi.
Monal S: Which will help you connect to our Wi-Fi. Now, tell me which one is better. Option 1.
Monal S: If Wi-Fi available, Connect it. I'm just writing without a coding, but just a syntax, okay?
Monal S: If… See this. If… Wi-Fi available.
Monal S: Then we will connect.
Monal S: This is option 1. Okay, let me erase this and write option 1.
Monal S: better.
Monal S: This is option 1.
Monal S: Option 2.
Monal S: If… Wi-Fi available.
Monal S: Connect.
Monal S: Else?
Monal S: tell user… No Wi-Fi available.
Monal S: You as a customer, which one do you want?
Monal S: Why you don't want option 1? Can you tell me why you don't want option 1?
Monal S: Because it is not user-friendly.
Monal S: If user wants to connect to Wi-Fi, and that application will never tell us that, no, Wi-Fi is available, you are not able to connect, then user will be like, okay, my Wi-Fi is available, but my internet is not working.
Monal S: So, option 2 is more user-friendly. Although else can work without if, if you're… it depends on the developer. If you want to provide a better experience, maybe do something else, if something is not working.
Monal S: Encoding, you will use this as well, this as well, but again, based on the scenario. Wherever you want to make friendly, make it this. Wherever you only want to check, use this.
Monal S: Are we clear? Both of them are important, but where you want to use it totally depends on you.
Monal S: This is Control Flow, but this is, again, in today's topic, I told you about control flow.
Monal S: That we have two different levels.
Monal S: Alright? Can we jump to the next one? Everyone, are we ready for the next one? Simple! It is also simple, but this time, it is a little advanced on the basic effects.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: Now we are going to control flow too. We have done a lot of things today, right?
Monal S: You guys are enjoying the class?
Monal S: Yep.
Monal S: Control Flow 2. There is nothing like Control Flow 2, but I'm just dividing it to beginner and advanced part, alright?
Monal S: So, the basic part was, if… if…
Monal S: condition, I'm just going to write it in short. If condition, then we have something.
Monal S: Then we'd do something.
Monal S: Do something.
Monal S: Again, do something.
Monal S: We have also seen simple if condition, Do something.
Monal S: But in real world, we don't just have condition, then do something.
Monal S: It's like, if my requirement is to buy 4 apples, if the shop does not have 4 apples, if the shop does not have 4 apples.
Monal S: Either I can go home, or I can just buy 3 apples. Yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: Or we can go to our next shop.
Monal S: In real world, we don't just have one condition and one final thing if we don't satisfy the condition. In real world, we do have multiple levels.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: We do have multiple levels. Similarly, control flow have multiple levels.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: If condition is present, this is the first thing, do something.
Monal S: If this condition does not satisfies, instead of doing the final thing, maybe we can check for another condition.
Monal S: We call it as LIF.
Monal S: Say this, we call it as… L if.
Monal S: And again, write a condition and do something.
Monal S: We can write as much ALIF as possible, as much required as possible.
Monal S: It can be hundred, it can be thousand, it can be two.
Monal S: And if we want, we can write else, but else is, again, an optional one.
Monal S: If you think none of the conditions satisfies, and you want to do still something, then you will go with ELF. Otherwise, if you want multiple conditions to be tested, you will do this. But you cannot have ELIF alone without having if.
Monal S: This is not acceptable.
Monal S: You require if in order to write the LIF. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Indentation is always… guys, tell me, why do we require indentation? I told you.
Monal S: What is the meaning of indentation to a programming language?
Monal S: So that it can differentiate which part belongs to something.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: which part belongs to something, to understand which block, which area belongs to some condition. That's why indentation is there. In if, again, if I not provide indentation, what will happen? Same error, not error. Same thing, Python will not be able to understand.
Monal S: So, understand the concept, No, my question is, if Alif has to start with indentation.
Monal S: No, it is on the same. Guys, see this. If, LF, LF, LF, else, all of them have the same level.
Monal S: Just like if and else belongs to the same level.
Monal S: Are you clear? Guys, this is not Java, we don't require these blocks.
Monal S: In Python, we don't require it.
Monal S: Another one, this is not acceptable, so let me mark it as cross.
Monal S: another.
Monal S: This is if, Aleph, Aleph, and this is also Aleph, okay?
Monal S: I also wanted to tell you one more thing.
Monal S: Rohit, because Python developers don't require it, indentation is the curly braces. In Java, you don't require indentation.
Monal S: Rohit, yes?
Monal S: Java uses curly brackets to define the area. Python uses indentation to define the area.
Monal S: Now, people are asking, what is elif? LIF is just like IF, but it will only work with if.
Monal S: If this, I will tell you guys, I will tell you. Okay, there are a lot of Rohit, yes. Don't worry, guys, I will tell you. See this example? Only after example, we will understand what to do with that, okay?
Monal S: Say this. Where is our code? Here is the code.
Monal S: Now we are in control flow 2, or I will just write… If… I live else.
Monal S: Now see this.
Monal S: I am going to define operation name.
Monal S: Okay? And here, we will write something. This was marked down, let me select it as Python.
Monal S: Okay, sometimes this Python becomes marked down. So, see this, what I'm trying to do, then you will understand when to use it, where to use it.
Monal S: If… The operation name is equals to add.
Monal S: Just like a calculator. Then we will print.
Monal S: Perform addition.
Monal S: Only one condition.
Monal S: Alright? Now, suppose I want to have multiple conditions.
Monal S: I will write LF.
Monal S: If operation is equal to subtract, We will perform subtraction.
Monal S: Else?
Monal S: Let's do… no operation.
Monal S: Name found.
Monal S: No selected operation name form.
Monal S: So, let's define operation name as data.
Monal S: Now, see one by one, everyone. I'm not going to repeat it. I am not going to repeat it. I know a lot of people are here in the chat. Guys, please focus here.
Monal S: Data is operation name, operation name have data.
Monal S: Tell me, is this condition true?
Monal S: Is this condition true? Is data equals to add? False.
Monal S: If false.
Monal S: Python will go inside here, yes or no? Python will not go inside and execute. What is the next line? Next line is elif.
Monal S: Here, what we are doing… Is data ecosystem subtract?
Monal S: No, false. Python will not go inside, check in the same level, what is the next code? Next code is else.
Monal S: Else does not have any condition, it means it will work always.
Monal S: It will work only when the above conditions are false.
Monal S: Guys, make sure that you remember this. ELSE will only work when above condition are false. If any of the condition is true, we will not even go to else.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: I hope everyone understood this before.
Monal S: So, because both the conditions are false, we will go to else and say, no selected operation name found.
Monal S: Parking?
Monal S: Let's add another ALIF to make it More, bigger. Divide.
Monal S: perform division.
Monal S: Same thing will happen.
Monal S: it will not work. None of the conditions are getting satisfied. Now, if I do divide.
Monal S: If I do divide.
Monal S: This one will not work, condition does not satisfies. When it will go to the second L if, condition is not satisfying. When it will go to elif, this will work. Once it is true, it will not even go to the else block. This is considered it as whole control flow, one control flow block.
Monal S: After that, we can print.
Monal S: Program ended.
Monal S: So what we will see, guys, if any of them here is true, it will… it will do the work inside it, and then go to the same level and jump out of… this is the whole control flow. I will write in comments.
Monal S: This is Control Flow Start, And in else block, control flow ends.
Monal S: So, what we found, when the operation name is Divide, this one worked, it performed the code written inside it, then we jump to the… we jump out of the control flow.
Monal S: So, what we have seen…
Monal S: If any of the condition is true, it will do the job. Then, after doing the job, it will not do any check. It will jump out of the code in the same level after the control flow.
Monal S: Sir, what if we remove else and don't use print statement outside the go? Guys, what will happen? You're asking?
Monal S: What will happen now?
Monal S: What will happen now? We will only see the work of perform division.
Monal S: Is there any code after the control flow? No code, it will do nothing.
Monal S: Yes, Priya, I will talk about it.
Monal S: Is this part clear, guys?
Monal S: Guys, if you don't use else, Are you getting error?
Monal S: People are saying we are getting error.
Monal S: Now, the next part, the final part, then will give you… guys, control flow can work. It does not give you error.
Monal S: Now, people will ask, there is a certain kind of a thing. There are a lot of permutation combinations. I hope everyone is clear with this combination.
Monal S: Everyone is clear with this combination.
Monal S: Yes Now, the next code.
Monal S: Why not use…
Monal S: Why not use multiple if, why use ELIF?
Monal S: How many of you have this question?
Monal S: Why not use multiple if when we have…
Monal S: When we have it, why to use LIF?
Monal S: The answer lies in start and end block. Guys, Whenever we start if, It starts… It starts… Control… flow…
Monal S: block.
Monal S: Whenever a new again starts, it again starts… A new control flow.
Monal S: Again, we saw… Again, it starts…
Monal S: And here, if I write ALIF, Here, if I write Aleph.
Monal S: And again, if I write another if condition.
Monal S: Then this block will end here.
Monal S: And here we will get a new start.
Monal S: So whenever we get a new if, whenever we get a new if, guys, it starts a new block. What will happen in a new block? Say this.
Monal S: As I mentioned, this is a new block. Is this part clear, guys?
Monal S: This whole thing is a new block. Is this part clear?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Now, see what will happen.
Monal S: Let me copy everything.
Monal S: And this time, I will write it as if.
Monal S: So this one means control flow ended here. Is this part clear? Control flow ended here? Because we are getting new if. Is this part clear?
Monal S: When a new if is introduced.
Monal S: Control flow we start. So, how many blocks of control flow we have here?
Monal S: How many blocks of control flow we have here? Two.
Monal S: Now, see what will happen.
Monal S: Operation is equals to divide.
Monal S: Is operation is equals to divide.
Monal S: Is operation is equals to divide?
Monal S: False.
Monal S: It will not go inside.
Monal S: But it will not jump to the end.
Monal S: It will jump to the next line in the level where the control flow ended.
Monal S: Okay, see this? Control flow ended here. Now it will again start if operation is equals to divide? No.
Monal S: it will not perform this, it will perform this, and you will see this code. But see now, when I do add.
Monal S: when I do add, And again, let me add this code here as well.
Monal S: Multiple blocks.
Monal S: Still tell me how many control flows we have, guys.
Monal S: How many control flows we have here now? Still two.
Monal S: Operation name is equals to add.
Monal S: Will this work?
Monal S: We will see perform addition here.
Monal S: Is the block ended? Is the block ended?
Monal S: block ended, we are here. Now, Python will again start, because this is a new if, it will again check, and will this work? Will this work?
Monal S: We will see add.
Monal S: So, we will see perform addition two times.
Monal S: And now, see the fun thing? If I make it as a LFIF,
Monal S: Now, although we have two same conditions, only one will work. Why? First of all, operation name is equals to add.
Monal S: Is this true?
Monal S: Because there is no F, It will be a single block. Are we able to understand now?
Monal S: It is now a single if, single block. Will it go to the next one? Will it go to the next one? It will not go, because in a block of if-elif-else, only one of them is true, and then it will directly jump after the control flow. Ended.
Monal S: So, it will only work one time.
Monal S: So, if marks…
Monal S: if marks a new start of the control flow, Python, if sees another if, that is another if condition, it will again check.
Monal S: But here, only one of them is true in a block. In the previous case, when I talked about it, here we have two control flow. It will do check two times.
Monal S: How… when to use Double AF? Guys, when to use Double AF? Let's see.
Monal S: Age is equals to 19.
Monal S: And, batch is equals to 2.
Monal S: And let's say, now…
Monal S: Passion number is equals to, guide, what session it is, is it third class or fourth class?
Monal S: Is it 3rd or 4th? 3rd class?
Monal S: Fourth from the, main class, right?
Monal S: Second, actually, guys, it is for, we have orientation also, right?
Monal S: See this? If age is greater than 19, They will say…
Monal S: They will print something. Let's say I'm printing 19. I'm only printing dummy thing, we don't want to waste time.
Monal S: Now we want to check something else, so we will check… If badge is… greater than 1.0.
Monal S: Then, we will say… in double codes, give access to V1.0
Monal S: Then we will do another check.
Monal S: If session number is equals to…
Monal S: Greater than 1, they will print.
Monal S: Induction and data.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: See, here we are working with different, different values to check different conditions.
Monal S: Here, we will check if any of them is true. Here, we are doing multiple conditions. Are you able to find a difference?
Monal S: See, here we have two prints because this is one block, this is another block, this is another block.
Monal S: How many blocks we have here? One block?
Monal S: 2 block, 3 block. How many blocks we have here?
Monal S: one block, 2 block.
Monal S: How many blocks we have here?
Monal S: One block.
Monal S: So guys… This is how we should understand coding. Let me write it, block start, block end.
Monal S: I'm giving some space so that it will… it is clear for you to remember it later.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: The difference is what we are trying to do. If we understand the fundamental of if and else, then it makes sense. We are asking the question because a lot of if confuses us with if-elif-elif.
Monal S: Someone is asking why 19 is not printed, because age is… guys, Is 19 greater than 19?
Monal S: Is 19 greater than 19?
Monal S: 19 is equals to 19.
Monal S: So, greater than will not work. In order for it to work, you can use either this or this.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Guys, ask that question. Is 19 greater than 19? No, it can't be.
Monal S: I hope everyone is clear.
Monal S: Guys, it requires little practice, but is everyone clear?
Monal S: Difference here is… Guys, what is different between Ali for switch? Switch is also there in Vita.
Monal S: Devanishi.
Monal S: Guys, similar to Switch, we have something.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: We'll talk about that later, not now.
Monal S: So guys, if-else also has something called as nested, but in today's class, it will create little chaos, okay? So, nested, if and else, we will understand it later.
Monal S: Is that fine?
Monal S: Or do you want to understand nested if-else?
Monal S: We will understand in depth, guys, okay? We will understand in depth. We can… we are done with control flow. In Control Flow 2, I will give you more assignments there.
Monal S: But what we will do, I will start with primitive, just the introduction, but we will complete the primitive in Wednesday class.
Monal S: Okay? So guys, see this. Understand the next topic.
Monal S: We are covering a lot of things. I know there will be a lot of revisions required from all of you.
Monal S: But, this is Control Flow 2 Advance. Advance has one more part, which I… we will do it later.
Monal S: Guys, Wednesday, we will have usual class. Wednesday is not doubt class.
Monal S: Okay, now jump to the final topic.
Monal S: It will… I will only introduce it, but later we will talk about how to perform coding and all. If time permits, we can also do it. Okay.
Monal S: So, primary data types… primary… data types, of Python.
Monal S: Or any languages, the base data types is called as primitive data types.
Monal S: Primitive, data type. What are the perimity data types we have understood?
Monal S: Guys, tell me… We have seen integer, float, String Boolean.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Now, there are data types which are made for other purpose. Here, we have seen that I have to create A equals to 2, or if I want to create ID of person 1, I will write a variable ID1, and their ID.
Monal S: If another ID is there, I have to create another variable, write their ID.
Monal S: If there are thousand such people.
Monal S: Dive, we need to create thousand variables, yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: So this is now an issue.
Monal S: We require a different way to deal with the data.
Monal S: We cannot deal with primary data types, we require a different, complex way to deal with data. And there comes non-primitive data types. Those are not the primary data types of the language.
Monal S: But it helps us a lot scale our application. Scale means improve, scale, store a lot of things in an efficient way. Those are called as…
Monal S: None… primitive data types.
Monal S: Are we clear? Here in Python, in Java, we call those as array. This is about Java, but we are not learning Java.
Monal S: It is not similar to Java, but it is kind of similar. In Python, we have something called as list.
Monal S: We have something called as list.
Monal S: Then, dictionary DICT.
Monal S: Then we have tuple.
Monal S: Then we have set.
Monal S: We have more, but these are the major types which we will be using.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Guys.
Monal S: Dinesh, tell me what arrays is… array, are you talking about NumPy? Do we have it in Python directly, or in NumPy?
Monal S: Danish?
Monal S: Can I write array?
Monal S: In Python directly?
Monal S: We don't have array.
Monal S: It is not native to the Python. It is native to some other library, alright? We are talking about Python here, we will understand this later.
Monal S: Okay? So, list. Now, I will talk about list, okay?
Monal S: This is how we create a list.
Monal S: List starts with square bracket, square bracket.
Monal S: A square bracket, and ends with closing square bracket.
Monal S: Closing… Square bracket.
Monal S: In between, we write values R… Values are, comma, separated.
Monal S: and then we provide a variable name here. We don't write list, but we write a variable name here. Simple example. Simple example.
Monal S: Let me write…
Monal S: more data types.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Let's suppose I want to create IDs of people. So, I have created a variable name IDPeople.
Monal S: Sri, if primitive means the base of any language, the basic language, non-primitive means that is not directly from the language, it is made from compounding or other things, okay?
Monal S: ID people I have created, then here I can write 100, 101, 102, whatever I want. 103, 104, 105. I can write thousands of people ID in the same variable.
Monal S: Is it better than creating thousand different variables?
Monal S: Now, see how to print it.
Monal S: Are we able to see all of them?
Monal S: Are we able to see all of them? Yes.
Monal S: Let's go to the little depth.
Monal S: In Java and other languages, we have array.
Monal S: An array at a time can store only one data type.
Monal S: Suppose this array consists of only what kind of values?
Monal S: We are not talking about Python, but we are talking about other language.
Monal S: It consists of only integers.
Monal S: This array consists of… Hello?
Monal S: Word.
Monal S: This area is only STR.
Monal S: In Python, we don't have array. This is, let me write, not Python.
Monal S: In Python, we have a flexibility, we have a list.
Monal S: List can store integers, it can also store float, it can also store my name.
Monal S: in a single list. So these are integer, float, and string.
Monal S: It does not gives you an error.
Monal S: So, lists are powerful. So, serious. Now, instead of ID people, can I write
Monal S: ID is 101.100102, and let's write their grade ABC, that is a string.
Monal S: In small b, I can also write… I can also write… Let's say, some decimal.
Monal S: I can also write Boolean.
Monal S: Is it working?
Monal S: Guys, in Python, a lot of the things are dynamic. Devanshi?
Monal S: It is dynamic.
Monal S: It acquires the space based on the values.
Monal S: Guys, there is no limit, you can fill as much values as you want.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: And guys, if I print the type.
Monal S: if I print the type of people, I should see what I should see what… List.
Monal S: And if I print, if I print using the original Pythonic way.
Monal S: It is a class of type list.
Monal S: And tell me what I'm trying to do here.
Monal S: Tell me, is this a function or a method?
Monal S: Is this a function or a method? You guys will tell me.
Monal S: Why it is a method?
Monal S: Why we are calling it as a method, or a property.
Monal S: Why we're calling it as a property?
Monal S: Because it uses dot, And it is a property or attribute of people.
Monal S: People is nothing but list. List is a class.
Monal S: Now, see what I'm doing. The original list has true at the last element.
Monal S: Now, let me append…
Monal S: Data science. See, in append bracket, I'm writing the value. It can be anything. Guys, see this? I'm telling you.
Monal S: Let's print the… let's print people now.
Monal S: What happened?
Monal S: Sri, what happened?
Monal S: It appended… it appended a new value at the end of the people list.
Monal S: Are we able to understand?
Monal S: Praveen, why do you have string in quotes? Praveen?
Monal S: Guys, why do we have string in quotes?
Monal S: Without codes, you cannot have string.
Monal S: Arachana, correct?
Monal S: String is always coded, you cannot create a string without a double quote or single quote.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this method?
Monal S: Hi, everyone!
Monal S: Now, let's go to more advanced version of list, then I will not teach you more. It will be enough for today's class, okay? Now, where do we use list?
Monal S: Let's talk about the problem statement. We can have n number of problem statements, but one of them is, I want to create
Monal S: information, I want to create people register.
Monal S: It means information about people. When someone… when people register, this one is used for… you're building
Monal S: Entry register. When someone enters in your building, you want your security guard to enter their details.
Monal S: Usually, what details we will pick? What is their name?
Monal S: What is their phone number? What is their address?
Monal S: At what time they are in.
Monal S: As well as, at what time they are out, And what is their reason?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Purpose? Yes, reason is purpose.
Monal S: Yes, guys?
Monal S: And usually the flat number.
Monal S: So, how many variables we need? 1.
Monal S: 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Monal S: So we require 7 variables here, and all of these 7 variables we require for 1 person.
Monal S: If I have 100%,
Monal S: I have to create 100 times 7, that is 700 variables, to store only 100 people.
Monal S: Does this sound good?
Monal S: As a developer, if you… if someone will ask you to write all of different variables, does this sound good?
Monal S: No, it does not.
Monal S: No, it does not. So what we can do, say this, what we can do, we can create
Monal S: We can take all of these variables, 1, 2, 3, I'm not writing the value, I'm just writing the numbers. 5, 6, 7, in a list.
Monal S: So, for single person, I will have…
Monal S: for single person, I will have a single variable. Yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: Yes, for a single person, I will have a single variable, which will have 7 values. Only one variable name.
Monal S: For hand rate, for hand rate, how many variables I have to create?
Monal S: For 100 people, how many variables I have to create?
Monal S: 100 variables in total.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So, all the way from 700 to 100, we were able to reduce number of variables. Is this a better solution?
Monal S: Is this a better solution?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: We can do further optimization.
Monal S: What we can do, Person 1 is already a list.
Monal S: I can create a register, I can create a register which is already an empty list. I will tell you how to create an empty list. This is an empty list.
Monal S: Why not I can use register, dot append To append person.
Monal S: Append uses what? Value. Person 1 is a value or not?
Monal S: Person 1 is a value or not.
Monal S: Person 1 is also a value.
Monal S: How many var- how many variables I need now?
Monal S: How many variables I need now?
Monal S: Run.
Monal S: Now see this in action.
Monal S: let's create… I'm not going to create those 7 variables, but I will create… Let's say, name.
Monal S: Okay, I will create name, So, first, let's create the register.
Monal S: Register is empty, but empty is also a list, yes or no?
Monal S: Just like, similarly, we can have name as empty string.
Monal S: if I print name, it is still, it is empty, but it is still… But it is still…
Monal S: a string.
Monal S: print.
Monal S: Type of name.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: It is empty, but it is still a string. Is everyone clear with this concept?
Monal S: Is everyone clear with this concept? Similarly, I'm going to comment it. This is for our own use case, okay? It will make our notes bad.
Monal S: So, I've created a register which is empty, and if you want to print the type of register, you will see class list. This is done.
Monal S: Now, what we will do? Register.append. What we require? We require value.
Monal S: Can I write something like this?
Monal S: Let's say flat number 101, my phone number 101 is, integer.
Monal S: my phone number is not an integer, because I want to add that Extension. Not extension.
Monal S: So, I will write 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 0. We cannot write this in integer plus 91, okay? Then, let's write the reason. We will just write visit.
Monal S: Is this fine?
Monal S: Is this fine, guys?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand? This is nothing but a value. Either I can write it like this, or I can create a variable
Monal S: And pass the variable inside append, both of them are same.
Monal S: Both of them are same, yes or no.
Monal S: But here we are only using one variable, and below we are using two.
Monal S: Guys, tell me first whether you are able to understand that both of the codes are doing the same thing.
Monal S: I want everyone to say yes, no, very simple.
Monal S: List inside a list? Yes.
Monal S: So what I'm going to do, I am commenting this so that you guys can see, what we are doing. So, register.append, we are appending a list itself.
Monal S: Done. Code is done. Now let's print the register and see what it is doing.
Monal S: There is that empty list. Inside that, we have the new value. This whole thing is a new value.
Monal S: Now, what I will do… Now, I will write Pradeep Snake.
Monal S: Pradeep.
Monal S: Okay, I saw your name, Pradeep, and I've written it.
Monal S: I am running again. What will happen? We are asking to append again another value in the register.
Monal S: If I print the register, what will happen?
Monal S: Mona is the first one, this value is the first one. Now, inside it, we have second.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Now, someone is asking that, why do we have two brackets? It is a visualization thing that you need to understand. See this?
Monal S: Everyone who thinks, why in real time it won't happen, it will happen. Guys, in real time it happens.
Monal S: This is our original register.
Monal S: This is the value which we are appending.
Monal S: Here, it already have a bracket. This one is our register, which already has a bracket. These…
Monal S: This is different from this one. How many of you agree?
Monal S: This value is different, this value is different. Yes.
Monal S: If I add this value here.
Monal S: It will look like this, yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: This whole thing is one value. We are inserting one value.
Monal S: If I insert another value, 1, 4, 5, 6,
Monal S: In this list, which already has a value, what will happen? This is the first value, 1, 2, 3, 4. We are appending a new.
Monal S: New means comma separated, because we need a… we need a differentiating factor.
Monal S: 1, 4, 5, 6.
Monal S: This is one value, see this?
Monal S: This is one value, this is another value, and the white one is the original register, this one.
Monal S: Between that, we have these values. Are we clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: And guys, List does not care if the first one has 4, second one has 10.
Monal S: For list, It is nothing but a value.
Monal S: Let me show you multiple… We are just doing experimentation on lists.
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: Let's create… I'm calling this list as dummy.
Monal S: This is dummy.
Monal S: Dummy's empty.
Monal S: Now what I'm doing, I'm using dummy.append to add the value, I added 0.
Monal S: And here, I will keep on printing the same cell, because I don't want to write a lot of print.
Monal S: Does this look good?
Monal S: Guys, is this looking good?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Now, what I will do, if I run this same cell, what will happen, guys?
Monal S: If I run this same block, what will happen? If I run the same block, what will happen?
Monal S: 0 get added again. So if I print dummy again, Is this correct?
Monal S: Is this correct? So, how many times I will use append value gets added.
Monal S: Now, instead of 0, I will add hello.
Monal S: looks correct.
Monal S: Append does not care what happens in between, it only requires value.
Monal S: This is also a value.
Monal S: This whole thing is also a value. If I run again, what you will see?
Monal S: This whole thing is a value.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand?
Monal S: Everyone.
Monal S: Again, I want to add new. Now, this list has, again, hello, my name, And my flat number.
Monal S: This is a new value. What list will do the new… what list will do to the new value?
Monal S: It will again do its job, append it.
Monal S: If I print it, I will see a new value separated by comma series.
Monal S: Comma inside a list is different, but if you see from the main high level, from the first level, it is separated by its own comma.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Now, I will show you one function. See this?
Monal S: Function is called as len, L-E-N.
Monal S: In this function, if we provide any class where we have multiple values, I will talk about it in the next class, it is called as iterables. If I provide dummy, guys, what is dummy?
Monal S: What is dummy? Agrawal, next class.
Monal S: Dummy is a list.
Monal S: What is 5?
Monal S: 5 is number of elements. Let's count element 1, element 2, element 3, Element 4… Element 5.
Monal S: Is this correct?
Monal S: Encore int is not list is retriever.
Monal S: Ravi Kair is not there.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: So guys, there are lots of things. Primitive data types is the base of your coding. It will take time, but in today's class, I just want you to introduce on the powerful data types which we require.
Monal S: Which we cannot do with simple primitive data types, but it is made from
Monal S: All of these are nothing but primitive only, yes or no. Guys?
Monal S: All of this are nothing but primitives only. Combinations of primitives create non-primitives in Python. So, guys.
Monal S: Am I using length from list, or length on list?
Monal S: Say this, this is a function.
Monal S: But append is… Append is a method of list.
Monal S: Append is a method of list.
Monal S: So, make sure that you write this in notes.
Monal S: Alright? And this completes our today's class, and I hope everyone is happy with today's class. Guys.
Monal S: All of you are happy with today's class?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So, what is your job, guys? What is your assignment, again?
Monal S: Because we are in the beginner level, I want all of you to revise each and everything as much as you can.
Monal S: The more you revise, the more you understand.
Monal S: So again, it is a poll time. In the meantime, let me zip all of this content so that I can paste it in the community. Guys, task I will give you from the next class, Wednesday's class.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: And personally, guys, the way I'm teaching this slow, I hope
Monal S: C-sharp means both. Gaurav, in C-sharp auto, it is different. Property… Gaurav, if you understand C-sharp, property is a part of class. Property is not a part of normal code.
Monal S: Property is nothing but method. It is just an interchangeable name. I will talk… I will teach you that in oops.
Monal S: Okay, so let me save everything, save today's notes as well.
Monal S: And guys, the slow I'm teaching, I am thinking that none of… very less of you is going to have doubt.
Monal S: 2026 notes.
Monal S: Guys, right now, I will not suggest you to do practice. If you forget your foundation… if you forget your foundation and work on just coding, you will not understand. Revise each and everything what I'm teaching.
Monal S: Guys, give me a second. I'm not able… I'm not currently seeing your chats. I'm focusing on providing you notes.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: Press to zip…
Monal S: This is data science.
Monal S: our badge, and zip is there. And guys, I really like that you guys are also helping other people in the community, and this is what I want.
Monal S: I will jump in whenever I can, and whenever you guys are not able to solve it, I do that, but in the meantime, if other people are able to help, that is,
Monal S: That is more than required, and thank you very much for that.
Monal S: Guys, notes I have appended in the community, I will also send in our chat here.
Monal S: I mean, guys, I will talk about there are a lot of different methods which we are going to do for the list. For now.
Monal S: We will not do that.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: to later class. We will learn all of that in next class.
Monal S: Practical, Level 1… Lectures, 18 and 18.
Monal S: I've also sent that in our…
Monal S: in our, Zoom chat, so you guys can also check it.
Monal S: There are, again, people who is giving me 1-2-star feedback, I'm not sure.
Monal S: I will suggest them to have course from Scalar and other companies, then they will know what is going on in the market.
Monal S: Guys, next class will be more on the data types, and we will also go into the loops part. Loop is very important. Without loops, you cannot do much of a coding.
Monal S: Guys, color theme, I am using, I think, Cyberpunk. You guys can check it.
Monal S: Which headphones I use? Guys, this is Sony WX000MX5.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Vishnu. Thank you, guys.
Monal S: Accident class date, guys.
Monal S: Only if you have doubt regarding today's class, then let's do it, because once you jump to the more complex part, then it is good for you to advise which path to spread. Right now, if you go to any other path, you will fail. If you don't want to fail, stay in this path until you get some… your grounds clear.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Guys, Bitwise is not for us as a data scientist. It might be used for some other program who is creating electronics, they want to create a simulator or something, but for now, you… guys, I've shared the code as well, it is present in the zip.
Monal S: Naman, if you want to do that, do it. Why you want to do that, Naman?
Monal S: Print dummy is greater than zero. What is the use of, print? Naman, tell me.
Monal S: Naman, tell me what is the use of print.
Monal S: If you guys will ask me some other question, now I will cross-question your base, which I've taught.
Monal S: Assignments, guys, the today assignment is revise as much as you can. Assignments will be from next class.
Monal S: Guys, yesterday class is also… yesterday file is also present, I have downloaded it yesterday night.
Monal S: yesterday class. Guys, whoever does not have doubt, you can leave, and whoever is having doubt.
Monal S: I know a lot of people will not have doubt, and guys, happy Sunday, thanks for attending. It's a great weekend to teach you guys, and this is the first week which we have completed, and we'll see you next Wednesday, alright?
Monal S: Thank you, guys, thank you very much.
Monal S: Wednesday class is 2 hours, and there we will not have doubt session, as I mentioned, because we don't have time for doubt. So it will be a light topic, in-depth, but doubts part will be clear on Friday.
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys, thank you. And don't forget to create LinkedIn posts, because you get more clarity there.
Monal S: If you tag me and Chris, sir, we also comment, we also like on that comment. Again, it's the way you write your post. In that way, you will also learn to create posts, so if you do that, it will be more than enough for you, because when you're going for job hunting and others, people will be able to see, yes? Whoever has doubt, please raise your hand.
Monal S: I will start with Shiva.
Monal S: Shiva? Yes, thank you very much, guys.
Monal S: Hey, Shiva.
Siva Subramanian: Hi, Monal. It's a great question, Monal.
Siva Subramanian: Thank you for the question. I have one doubt, regarding that, reviewing the courses. So, I, I just want, saw that, Ultimate Data Sciences are GenA Last Year courses also.
Monal S: Cool.
Siva Subramanian: So that also, it's around more than 2 to 4 hours. And these courses, I have downloaded all the courses.
Siva Subramanian: But, pre-request courses, like, YouTube, like, Krishna, like, have attached this, YouTube prerequest code, like, Python.
Monal S: prerequisite, it's not a prerequisite. It's a way, if you want to fast-track your learning, you can watch those. It's not a prerequisite. Prerequisite I'm teaching, I'm teaching you from the memory itself. What is a computer? You will not get it on the YouTube.
Siva Subramanian: Yeah, yes, yes, your course is also there, I downloaded. But what the thing is, I don't know how to manage and review back and back, so it's a long time.
Monal S: you have to do? See, you're attending live sessions, right?
Siva Subramanian: Yeah.
Monal S: Batch for recording is for people who want to watch it in a faster pace.
Siva Subramanian: Alright.
Monal S: This version is if you want to start from scratch and don't want to watch the batchman recording.
Monal S: That's all. Why you're watching Batch 1 and Batch 2, it is a lot of works, you know.
Monal S: Either watch batch one and complete that path, because that is already an ongoing course, or stay here if you want, if you like live sessions, if you want to… because that is also taught by me, right?
Siva Subramanian: Yeah.
Monal S: So you can go… why do you want to focus on both ways? That is an additional option that you have.
Siva Subramanian: So, yeah, yes, yes, clear. So, this five courses which you have completed, like, basics, so I, I can watch, one time and, taking notes.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes, that's all.
Monal S: All right.
Siva Subramanian: Yeah, yes, yes, clear, water, yeah, clear product, that's it.
Monal S: Alright, then we have Avni. Avni?
Monal S: Guys, no need to watch patch 1. It is only if you want to watch it and fast track your learning.
Monal S: But if you want to go in this page, it is cool.
Monal S: Monal, S5.
Monal S: Satya, according to your code, I will get, good, because 5 is greater than 5, it is false. I will go into…
Monal S: 5 is greater than 4.
Monal S: That is a good… But yeah, I understood, Satya. Yes, Avni, tell me.
Avni Yadav: Colonel, can you hear me?
Monal S: Yes, yes, I can.
Avni Yadav: Borilla, I have a question. Sorry, my name is coming as an incorrect one here. That's fine.
Avni Yadav: Question regarding the 17th January that you showed as the Jupyter file. I'm still not able to select the kernel there.
Monal S: Have you tried the solution which other people are using? I sh… I… Okay.
Monal S: Did you try.
Avni Yadav: Yeah, I tried… yeah, I tried few of those things, that, people have it online.
Monal S: Alright, okay.
Monal S: Can you share your screen? I'm converting you to panelists. Let's see what you're doing.
Avni Yadav: Cool.
Avni Yadav: I'm just trying to share my screen.
Monal S: The next pen tab, which I'm using is from Huan.
Monal S: And it is a very old one, I think this one is also already…
Monal S: Deprecated, they are not using it.
Monal S: The speaker, I'm not saying I only use headphones, this is Sony's headphone.
Monal S: Guys, as a data scientist, you don't require DSA, but as a software engineer, you require it. Alright, can you select kernel? Click on select kernel.
Avni Yadav: Yeah, so, kernel, I'm trying to say, select kernel, and I'm trying to look for level 1, level 1-ENV,
Avni Yadav: But I don't see… see that…
Monal S: We were able to see. That is the first one.
Monal S: There is a bigger star on that, yes.
Avni Yadav: Okay, it just came down. I restarted my, like… Yeah, sometimes you…
Monal S: You need to restart because it does not get populated. It's totally fine, I understand.
Avni Yadav: Thank you so much. Yeah, it's working fine, and thank you so much, like, really enjoying this class, so…
Monal S: Thank you very much, thank you.
Avni Yadav: Yes.
Avni Yadav: Hmm.
Monal S: Guys, your feedback really helps me a lot.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Devakar?
Monal S: Guys, my system configuration, my system configuration, I will tell you. Okay, just a second. Sorry for that.
Monal S: My system configuration is… I am using AMD Ryzen 9 7900X 12-core processor. I have 32GB of RAM. I am using NVIDIA RTX 4070 Super.
Monal S: And I also have NVIDIA inbuilt RAID and graphics card.
Monal S: So, this is my system compilation. Yes, debacle.
Diwakar IB: Yeah, two questions, Monol. So, first one is the intendation, whatever you told, it was giving in IPYNB, right? Will the same work for .py as well?
Monal S: It will work if you have installed Python.
Diwakar IB: Oh, okay.
Monal S: extension, right? It would work. We just could handle it, yes.
Diwakar IB: Okay, the second one is, the dummy, the experimentation list you shared, right? So the dummy, initially it was given at the null, right? And you gave print dummy and dummy.upund.
Diwakar IB: You open the normal brackets, and in that, you have given the… Square brackets, right?
Diwakar IB: So…
Monal S: Square bracket is a part of list. Normal bracket is just a part of your function's brackets. We will understand that later, but it is not a part of list. You can see, this is a bracket of append function, append method. Are you able to see? If I remove the list part from it, you will be left with append, just like a function, it looks… method looks, right?
Monal S: Format of the Apunished function. Yes, yes, yes.
Monal S: And between, you have that square bracket.
Diwakar IB: Okay.
Diwakar IB: Okay, thank you.
Monal S: Oh, alright, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, next one is… Nathan? Nathan Krishna?
Monal S: Because I don't use laptop. I was using laptop, but.
Nitin Krishna: Hi, hello, I don't… to put my doubts, like, do we have… where do we put the doubts?
Monal S: chat itself.
Nitin Krishna: It's webinar chat?
Monal S: Webinar chat, webinar chat.
Nitin Krishna: Okay. Or any other, like, WhatsApp, like, I don't know, like.
Monal S: No, no, okay.
Nitin Krishna: Where I missed it, I don't know.
Monal S: Or is it like the, where are you trying?
Nitin Krishna: I'm putting it here, where I've just put, hi, I have a doubt here, where you have shared in that, like, Zoom webinar, there I have put
Nitin Krishna: And also, I have to put it in that, the KISSNAC, web page there also, how it is, like, so, where I have to put it, so just…
Monal S: do this.
Nitin Krishna: I didn't get you.
Monal S: There are different kinds of questions that we use, alright? Are you able to see this screen?
Monal S: Yes. Are you able to say community?
Nitin Krishna: Yes.
Monal S: This is where we put questions. If you have questions after the class is over, you have some doubts, other people will help you. This is community. Is this part clear?
Monal S: This is where you put questions. When you have some doubt, other people will help you. I will jump it if other people will not be able to help you. Thank you very much, Momo. Is this part here? This is not for live session.
Monal S: Okay. Are you able to see this, chat section on my screen?
Nitin Krishna: Nope.
Monal S: I think this is because it is a part of Zoom, okay? It will not be able to show you.
Monal S: Alright, so, in Zoom, you will be able… you will see an option called as Chat, yes?
Nitin Krishna: Yeah, webinar chat, right?
Monal S: Can you please say hi? Can you please say hi there? Let's see whether your hi is coming or not.
Nitin Krishna: Yes, just now.
Monal S: Yes, I have… I am able to see your eye.
Monal S: Me, personally, I see your chat here, alright? And I might miss your chat because in a single second, there are a lot of people who are saying their questions or something, right? So your chat might be on top.
Monal S: Alright? And I might miss it. So, if you have doubt again, maybe you can copy and paste your query and then paste it again. Or, at the end, this… there are two channels. The last channel is, at the end of every doubt session, we raise the hand and then ask our query.
Monal S: That's the other 3 channels, alright?
Nitin Krishna: Yeah, understood.
Monal S: Yep.
Monal S: Thanks, Evan.
Nitin Krishna: Thank you so much, Late.
Monal S: You too.
Monal S: All right, Prince, we are next.
Monal S: Okay, Ananta, you will be next.
Monal S: Guys, don't put your Q&A section, because it is hard for me to look at chat, look at community, look at Q&A, it will be all over the place. Only chat.
Priince: I have not put anything in GoNet, sorry.
Monal S: No, no, no, no, I'm talking about other people on the chat, sorry. Sorry, guys.
Priince: Yes, so yesterday we have created, the lecture folder, right, in VS Code. And then, in that lecture folder, we have, created virtual environment. So, every time.
Monal S: Not inside lecture.
Monal S: Wait, yes, inside lecture, yes, inside lecture.
Priince: So, every time we create another folder in Level 1 or in Level 2 in future, so we have to, create this virtual environment, right?
Monal S: No, a virtual environment, just like I create… see, yesterday I created a folder. Today, also, I created a folder, yes.
Priince: Yes, but that was under the, this head lectures.
Monal S: Yes. So, this is the way I am telling you, you can use this virtual environment in lectures, in… if you create another folder, let's say I'm creating a folder called as XYZ,
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: In XYZ, I'm creating a notebook called as A.IPYNB.
Monal S: If I select a kernel, am I still able to see level 1 ENV, which is present here?
Priince: Yes.
Monal S: Do I need to clear it again? When we come out of level 1.
Priince: Yes. We are there in Level 2 and Level 3. So, for that, different levels, we have to create, we have to create these virtual environments.
Monal S: We will create it, that's why we are doing it, because if we require more advanced libraries, then we will jump to level 2. This is for maintaining, but when you create a project.
Monal S: Okay, I will tell you how do we… when we work in the real-world industry, what we do… let me go to the very end…
Monal S: In real world, in project, You are working on… on, let's suppose, ML project.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: You will start writing your code inside this folder.
Monal S: And inside this folder only, you create your VNV. You don't create outside.
Priince: Okay. That's all. This project is over.
Monal S: Another project, you create its own VNV. So, I just want all of you to have this practice of creating VNV for different projects. Right now, our project… think of our project as, like, Level 1 is our project.
Priince: Okay, got it.
Monal S: Got it.
Priince: And this is to maintain the different versions, right?
Monal S: to maintain different versions? Yes, they should maintain different versions.
Priince: Okay, okay, thank you.
Monal S: Yep, yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: That's great.
Monal S: Guys, I've already shared the zip in the community, please check it.
Monal S: I've already shared.
Monal S: others, please help people, if you can. Then we have Ananta, where we have an anthar.
Monal S: Guys, if you have similar questions, please unraise your hand. Ananda Lakshmi, you're next.
anantha lakshmi: Yeah, hi, Mona, this, very amazing… yeah, hello. I have, like, the same question, like, the previous person asked. So, suppose in the ML project, if we have too many levels, like level 1, level 2, level 3 in one project, can we install virtual…
anantha lakshmi: Can we…
Monal S: People have never seen a single project.
Monal S: Lovely.
Monal S: I am telling you so that because we are… we are learning. Learning has different levels. A project does not have level, a project has files.
anantha lakshmi: Oh.
Monal S: Is that clear?
anantha lakshmi: Oh, so for the one project, one time, we can install virtual environment, right? Yes, that's up there.
Monal S: Excellent.
anantha lakshmi: Thank you.
Monal S: Yep, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, and then we have Praveen.
Monal S: Pavin? Hey, Pavin.
Praveen Girotra: Thank you, Monuv.
Praveen Girotra: Academy.
Monal S: Yes.
Praveen Girotra: session, I think things are building up slowly. You know, a lot of confusion that we had… I had yesterday. I think, you know, it's, you know, coming back on track, so thanks for that. I had one request. I, you know, have the modules sprinted, and I'm, you know, trying to correlate to, you know, with the topics that we're covering.
Monal S: I mean, one, are we going through the module and sequence? Yeah, see, module has multiple topics, if you see, right? Correct. We are going through modules, but sequence, I might change it a bit. Correct. But not too much, not too much. Modules, we will go in sequence.
Praveen Girotra: Got it. And the other request is, is it possible for us to kind of get a table with timeline on how many, you know, weeks or months will we be doing, you know, Python and.
Monal S: I do have that timeline of the previous batch. Yeah, that would help, you know, all I'm looking at is an approximation. Yes, what I'm doing, Beth, I'm trying to add more things and speed up, because the previous batch, I took it more slowly. So I… that will be approximate, but this one will be faster than the previous batch.
Praveen Girotra: Yeah, I mean, all I'm looking at is an approximation, right? And in the next 3 months, you know, we do maybe Python.
Monal S: knowledge?
Praveen Girotra: Something like that.
Monal S: approximation to all of you guys, alright? I will send in the community.
Praveen Girotra: Just to understand that big picture, yeah, I appreciate that. Sure, sure. Thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, then we have HP.
Monal S: HP?
Monal S: Guys, you are seeing two classes for 17, because the recording was large, we have split it into Part 1, Part 2.
Monal S: Are we clear? 24071A7242.
Monal S: Guys, whoever doubt is cleared, they can leave this session. Enjoy your weekend.
Monal S: And thank you for joining, alright? Only people who has doubt, they can… they can stay, or whoever wants to listen to the doubt, they can also stay. Hey, HP, yes?
HP: Hi, Monal, thank you for the session. I… I just want to have one question that in Python can
HP: that we will use later for NumPy tabulations. Can hold multiple data types, like string, an integer, and every other thing.
Monal S: when we work in Python, we can create an array, but usually, when we work with computations, we create an array of a single type. It is an integer, we create with a single data type only, in numpy.
Monal S: Okay?
HP: Okay, okay. And, one question is related to the previous questions as well, like, we were discussing about the environment. So, since we have, we had created one project which is Level 1,
HP: So if I have to, like, run multiple environments, so I have to create multiple projects, like, if I have to run level 1 on 3.12, so I'll just execute that.
Monal S: a new environment, see this, I will tell you.
HP: Okay. Okay.
Monal S: And in NumPy, you can also create different values of array, but usually for the numbers, we convert for machine learning, we convert everything to numbers, alright? So don't worry about that. But here, I will talk about… see this.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: You can see level 1 is ENV.
HP: Yeah.
Monal S: You can create another environment within same level.
Monal S: While selecting, while selecting the environment, a new environment will be able to select from here. Are you clear?
Monal S: Yeah, I'm glad, I'm good. Thank you so much. Yes, yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: Yes, let me read one request from Arshis.
Monal S: Ashes, just give me a second.
Monal S: Ashesh, request to speed up things after… yes, Ashish, this is what I'm planning.
Monal S: And Ashish, yes, I totally understand, but sometimes what is my problem is.
Monal S: I… if I don't provide things in depth, it's like, I'm…
Monal S: how should I say it? If I don't provide in depth, I don't feel good. But I need to find a way in between so that you guys will be able to get the details.
Monal S: And also the speed. So I'm trying to figure it out, Ashish. But yes, if you see from the batch one, I'm already covering more concepts than the batch one. So I will speed up, yes. Thank you for that, Ashish.
Monal S: I will take… I will consider that, alright?
Monal S: Mansi?
Mansi Atara: Hey, good morning, Mona.
Monal S: Hey, Monty, yes.
Mansi Atara: Actually, I'm trying to find out the assignments in your resource tab, in the videos, but is it inside the zip folder of the date?
Monal S: It is inside the zip folder, and you will see assignments when I write. Have you seen the recording? How I provided assignment? Nancy?
Mansi Atara: Okay, you are saying to see the recording and check the assignments? I thought it will be a different folder.
Monal S: It is not a different folder. Assignments, I was… I am right… I usually write the assignments in the way I'm writing the notes, right?
Mansi Atara: Sure, sure, then it is okay, I was trying.
Monal S: When the assignments will be bigger, when the assignments will get bigger, the more coding part, then I will provide a separate assignments file.
Mansi Atara: Sure, sure, no problem. I was confused on that. It is clear. Thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: And there are some queries regarding how to check the resource. Guys, I hope everyone is able to see my screen.
Monal S: Hi, everyone?
Monal S: how to watch video, how to check resource, and other things. See this. I'm only showing you one time. After that, I will watch every… I will ask everyone to watch day one, day two, day 3.
Monal S: This is our course.
Monal S: And, you will not see all of that, you will see Ultimate Data Science Batch 2.
Monal S: If you click on that, you will see Get Started. These are the playlists Krisha provided if you want to go fast track. You can see RAG is there, Python is there, machine learning is there, if you want to do Fast Track. But these are not the live session. This is live session, you will see 11 gen, 11 gen day 1, day 2. Why? Because the session was very large.
Monal S: Then 14th gen, we only have one Wednesday class. 17th, we have Day 1, Day 2. Not Day 1, Part 1, Part 2, it means it was divided into two parts. It is the same day class. If you want to check the resource, click on any of the video, you will see Resource section here.
Monal S: This you will download. This is the same resource which I provide in the community.
Monal S: Alright? Is everyone clear now how to do it?
Monal S: Is everyone clear? This will happen For, for all the classes.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: How can we download the live sessions?
Monal S: you will not be able to download the live session, you have to watch it. If you download, you can upload to Telegram, and then…
Monal S: That is, again, a chaos.
Monal S: we will not allow any downloads. You will not be even able to do the screen recording.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So… That's… there.
Monal S: Alright, next is… Muhammad? Sharchil?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Yeah, hi, I'm…
Monal S: Hello, wait.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: I just wanted to ask about, the last part of the…
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: session. it was like, if you run again and again, it will… it is going to append and append, the data.
Monal S: Yes.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay.
Monal S: Because, see, if you press call button in your phone multiple times, what will happen? You will call that many times.
Monal S: Is it different from that?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Nope.
Monal S: Are you able to understand? We are running the… this is cell. We… here, I ran it one time. If I run it again, I'm running another time.
Monal S: But, if I run this, what will happen? Tell me. If I run this, what will happen?
Monal S: Dummy will become empty again.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay.
Monal S: is empty. Now, if I print the length, what will be the length?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Lero.
Monal S: Because I ran this cell again.
Monal S: Are you clear? Now it does not have zero hello, and other things. If I print this dummy, what will happen? It is empty.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: I'm doing it.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, and these blocks also… multiple blocks also interact with each other also.
Monal S: What do you mean?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: I mean… Yes,
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: If we, if we, dummy.app, append, if we press that, and we then, previous, one, print.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Then it will, again, print all the things.
Monal S: I will tell you what happens. These are different cells.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: This is just what? Your UI.
Monal S: Guess?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay.
Monal S: Behind it, they all share memory. Everything is stored in the RAM, yes?
Monal S: If you write A is equal to 2, in memory, what is the value of A?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: True.
Monal S: If you here make A is equal to 0,
Monal S: What will happen? A will become 0.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Doodle.
Monal S: If you print A here, or if you print A here, what it will do? Will it bring from here or here? No, it will bring from the memory. What is the value of A?
Monal S: Zero.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Mr. Muto.
Monal S: Again, if you print, 0, because it is printing from the memory.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, okay. And, one more thing you were, telling about, the previous course, 1.0. So, have you given access on, the, on the portal?
Monal S: you will get access, you might have got access, but if you don't, check with the team, they will give you access. But what you will see, I will show you.
Monal S: You will see in your courses, you will see two courses if you've enrolled in Data Sense 2. You will see 2.0, and you will also see this course as well.
Monal S: Are you clear? If you go
Monal S: courses, if you go to Courses tab in learn.rishnaacademy.com, in courses tab, you will see two courses here, if you have enrolled in 2.0.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, different end.
Monal S: Yes?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: This one and, the, previous one…
Monal S: This one, this is batch one?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay.
Monal S: Are we clear?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, okay, I can see. Okay, thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: Alright, and…
Monal S: Rithik Kumar, guys, if you write 10 times, I have a doubt, I have a doubt, what 11 people in the queue is doing.
Monal S: Retig and others, what 11 people is going to do.
Monal S: In the queue.
Monal S: Now, Rithik, I cannot see your hand raised also.
Monal S: I can see, Rithik Kumar Barnal, you are from last third.
Monal S: Right? So guys, everyone is on the queue. If you raise a hand, if another person will raise a hand, they will be standing at the last of the queue, just like an appended list.
Monal S: So it means those persons raise your hands again. It's totally fine, it's totally fine.
Monal S: But I'm just asking everyone, okay?
Monal S: Be considerate about others, it's totally fine. I know, everyone understands each other.
Monal S: But I have to say it one time, right? Don't worry, Redik.
Monal S: Ashish, you're next.
Ashish: Hey, hi!
Monal S: Yes.
Ashish: So, I just wanted to know, like, there's been, things when I… checking with the Christian Academy, they're saying that AI Pro subscription also is there, apart from this. So, what is that, like, they said that one year of subscription.
Monal S: AI Pro is a subscription which is not for 3 years, it is for 1 year, but in AI Pro, what… we can check with the sales team what is the latest date? Is it 1 year, 1.5 year? I'm not really sure, alright?
Monal S: when you buy AI Pro, whatever courses we have till now, okay, you will get subscription of those.
Monal S: Yes, all courses for that duration, 1 year. This Ultimate Data Science is for 3 years, but when you buy AI Pro, you will not get subscriptions for each and every courses. You will get all of them as a whole.
Ashish: Okay, whatever you've shown, whatever you've shown just now.
Monal S: Yes, yes, you will get all of them.
Monal S: you can check what are the courses you will get from the team, alright? But it is for one year. It is for people who want to learn everything. They are… they are experienced, they want to learn some concepts of the data science, but they also want to learn AgentK and RAG.
Monal S: If you buy all of these 3 courses, it might be more than the total courses amount. So, AIPro will give you all of them in a package, in a discounted price.
Ashish: But they are live class? They are live or recorded one?
Monal S: Yeah, live, live, live. See, for the courses that are going live, you will get live. For the courses that are already over, you will get recorded.
Monal S: Whatever we are going currently, it will be there. Whatever batches are done, you will also see that.
Ashish: So, but the timing will be closed, then?
Monal S: That part, see, it totally depends on, as I mentioned, right? It is not for people who are beginners, it is for people who know something, they want to learn, suppose in Ultimate Data Science, you have never learned machine learning. So you will join machine learning classes, but in the parallel, you can join RAG, you can do Agentic AI, RICLEAR,
Monal S: So, it is for pro, like, people who wants to get all the things, and they think that they will be able to complete it in one year.
Ashish: Okay, and then how explore, like, if you're going to see the course details and all, so… but.
Monal S: That details is not available to buy directly, but team will give you that link to buy it. You can check with the team that you can also tell that I have already enrolled in Ultimate Data Science, and I want to buy AI Pro, right? They will be subtracting that amount, and will give you AI Pro, if you require that.
Monal S: But, again, AI data science, this data science is for 3 years, that one will not be for 3 years.
Ashish: Yeah, and last question, like, that is fine, like, they will give you, whatever the courses, but I just want to, before purchasing, I just want to go through all the courses, like, what kind of courses are there.
Monal S: See, for that, what you can do, we will not be giving you access to recording just for you to try. What we can do is, I will show you.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: There's shh…
Monal S: Are you able to see this?
Ashish: Yes.
Monal S: Live classes, click on live classes, are you able to see 17 results. These are all the batches that we have done, we are done with, alright?
Monal S: It also includes Udemy one, but you can see, but what you can do, you can click on details. Let's suppose you want to go with Live Agentic Bootcamp. You will click on details.
Monal S: Then you will click on enroll now, then you will see this link off.
Monal S: syllabus. In every page, you will see the syllabus.
Ashish: Mother's.
Monal S: labor center and understand whether it suits you or not.
Ashish: That's what I was looking at you. So the website is different, krishnanag.
Monal S: Yes, this is the main landing page, this is only for learning.
Ashish: Can you paste it?
Monal S: resnag.in, I can paste that.
Monal S: Yes? Yeah, thank you so much. Yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: All right, yes, Ashish.
Monal S: Oh, sorry, I did something.
Monal S: Tetanya, you are next.
Monal S: Anya?
Chaitanya: Yeah, hi, Mona. Thank you. Thank you for the great sessions, and it's a really patience to take such a long session. Actually, I have a doubt in a previous session.
Chaitanya: Related to, virtual enrollment. In my, VC port, I am seeing two, virtual environments. Can you enable…
Chaitanya: Is that…
Monal S: Any one which you have installed.
Chaitanya: Let me… can you enable, my… Yes. Please join as a panelist.
Monal S: Yes, Jeff, I am.
Monal S: Appreciate it.
Chaitanya: Is my screen visible now?
Monal S: Not yet, it will be loading in 2 seconds.
Monal S: office, I will be planning, because every after Sunday, I plan weekends. But you can check the syllabus to check what topics will be coming.
Chaitanya: Anything…
Monal S: Yes, HRNA. It is.
Chaitanya: So, if you see in Lecture as I have created one virtual, environment called Test1.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, this one. When I am selecting the kernel… Select it, show me, show me.
Chaitanya: Okay, this is…
Monal S: Yes.
Chaitanya: Let me open this slide.
Monal S: Select kernel, select kernel. Select kernel is on top, right?
Monal S: No, no, top right, top right of the screen.
Chaitanya: Okay, this one. Okay. When I select kernel, it is showing C here.
Monal S: Okay, now, you see, don't select it. I will tell you what to do.
Monal S: Currently, you have opened Level 1, right?
Chaitanya: Correct.
Monal S: Right? And… You have opened, actually, UDS2. Can you open with VS Code Level 1 instead of UDS2?
Monal S: Go to File, and open the folder called as Level 1. Don't open UDS2.
Monal S: You can… you can close this whole VS Code, it's fine. Close the whole VS Code.
Monal S: Now, open… yes, Level 1 was there. Go to Level 1.
Monal S: Yeah, open this. Oh, no, no, go back, go back.
Chaitanya: Okay.
Monal S: Right-click on Level 1.
Monal S: Go to More Options.
Monal S: Okay, here it is not showing you VS Code? Okay, now open VS Code, and open this Level 1 folder from the VS Code.
Monal S: Click on File on top, click on File on top.
Chaitanya: Okay.
Monal S: Open folder.
Monal S: Now select Level 1.
Chaitanya: Okay.
Monal S: Yes, select and select folder.
Monal S: Yes, save all.
Monal S: How can you open lecture? Any of the notebooks?
Monal S: Open Notebook.
Chaitanya: Okay, this is new, okay, it's finished.
Monal S: Showing your detecting… okay, okay, can I… let's click on select kernel?
Monal S: Click on Python Environments.
Monal S: Okay, okay, so now it is still not showing you that.
Monal S: So… Wait, wait, wait. Don't do that.
Monal S: I want you to… Okay, let's… will you be able to create the environment again?
Chaitanya: Okay, then I need to delete this one.
Monal S: Delete test one, let's do it again, because…
Monal S: There is a workaround, but again, I have to do a lot of coding. Yeah, delete it.
Monal S: Open terminal here, open terminal here.
Monal S: Also, I think you created insight that, okay, Hmm… yes.
Monal S: OpenCMD?
Monal S: do UVENV.
Monal S: Movie?
Monal S: V-E-N-V?
Monal S: ENV. V-E-N-V.
Monal S: ENV, ENV. You forgot the commands already, Chadania.
Monal S: V, E, and ENV. Environment. E-N-V.
Monal S: Space, right, test underscore one.
Monal S: press enter.
Chaitanya: Yeah, hi.
Monal S: Are you able to see now?
Chaitanya: Yes, it is the… it is here. The test one is…
Monal S: You should, you should do parallel to your lecture now, okay?
Chaitanya: Okay.
Monal S: It's fine. Done.
Chaitanya: Yes.
Monal S: Anything else, Ethania?
Chaitanya: I, now see, here it is.
Monal S: Yeah, yes, yes, it is working.
Chaitanya: Got it, yeah. Good. Thanks. One more question, Monal. Regarding this Python sessions, how long it will be, take… how many months?
Monal S: Approximately, it took… in the previous one, it took around 1.5 months, but this batch, I will be completing it in one month.
Chaitanya: Okay, one month?
Monal S: That is my plan, that is my plan.
Chaitanya: Okay, got it.
Monal S: I will be giving an estimate, just like the person asked, right? What is the plan? So, I will give you how batch one happened. Approximate, it will take less than that. Alright?
Chaitanya: Okay, got it, got it. So, for Python, it will be one month, plus, machine learning, right?
Monal S: Python, after that, see the syllabus. There is a lot of thing after.
Chaitanya: Yeah, a lot of the things, yes, correct. A lot of things… lot of things are there, but we are not sure how long those will be taking. We are not new towards 100.
Monal S: on learning new things, see, if you keep on learning new things, this course and other things will kind of become secondary. I will be kind of your knowledge base, alright? I will be sharing my knowledge. But if you will be like, when course will,
Monal S: this course will be ending in one year. If you're waiting for one year to end something or to start something, that is a little bad. But once the Python and database part is done, you will be able to build something, alright? So don't worry on that.
Chaitanya: Okay, got, thank you. Sure, yes.
Monal S: Vamshi, see, I am planning, but plans…
Monal S: Anything can happen to the plant.
Monal S: Right, Vanshi?
Monal S: Dikran Lala?
Bikram Lala: Hey, hi.
Monal S: Hey, Degram.
Bikram Lala: See, actually, I'm opening this VS Code, but I'm not seeing that yellow color, actually, so just doubting if I'm missing some software in stone.
Monal S: What do you mean by that yellow color?
Bikram Lala: Oh…
Bikram Lala: It is, when you are, seeing your folder, right, it is, some highlight, yellow highlight, right?
Monal S: Ferris, I will tell you. Are you able to see my screen?
Monal S: You're talking about this yellow?
Bikram Lala: Things, yeah.
Monal S: see some other color. It is working or not, are you able to run code?
Bikram Lala: Yeah, yeah, I'm unable to run.
Monal S: This is my theme. Okay.
Bikram Lala: Okay.
Monal S: You can do any of the themes which you like. If you apply another theme, you can see there are lots of themes here. Select any of them, install it. If you want to click on item, install it, and apply it, you will see a different color. This is just a theme.
Bikram Lala: I got it, got it.
Monal S: And if you're not able to see something like this, where it's something like this, all different colors also.
Monal S: You can also install Python.
Monal S: But again, that is, again, depends on theme. This might be green for you, yellow for you, based on the theme, but you need to also install this Python. This will help you look for Python keywords and other things more clearly. Okay?
Bikram Lala: Yeah, we have installed this one, yeah, just…
Monal S: Alright, that is the other theme part only, okay?
Bikram Lala: Yeah, thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: Right? And, then we have… On this album?
Pandiselvam: I wanna…
Monal S: Hello, sorry if I'm not pronouncing your name correctly.
Pandiselvam: Yeah, yeah, correct.
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Pandiselvam: Yeah, Mona, yeah, I, yeah, already the two of them, they have an issue with the selected environment, right? So even I tried after your root causing, and still I couldn't, find the resolution. Can you help me here?
Monal S: Alright, sure. Can you please join as a panelist? Yes. Share your screen?
Monal S: Avine might do it later, but for now, if I do it, people will say.
Pandiselvam: Brilliant.
Monal S: Radeep, I know. Radeep, if possible, you can mention your query in the chat, because your name is after two people.
Monal S: If you can wait, that is fine. Yes, can you please open, CMD? You're working with PowerShell.
Monal S: That was the first requirement.
Monal S: Power, sir.
Monal S: No, no, no. CMD you can open here in VS Code.
Monal S: Can you see that downward-facing arrow right to the plus button? Right to the plus button?
Pandiselvam: Okay.
Monal S: Click on that, and select Command Prompt.
Monal S: Now you're in command prompt in VS Code, okay?
Pandiselvam: Okay, okay, understood.
Monal S: Okay, yes, so I can see this is what you are working with.
Monal S: But why you have created 17.01.2026 inside your virtual environment?
Monal S: Why do you have VNV lecture.
Pandiselvam: But this is the way you have structured the folder, or…
Monal S: Oh.
Pandiselvam: highly drawn. Highly drawn.
Monal S: You did it wrong.
Pandiselvam: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, so, but still, can you please,
Monal S: Okay, let's select on 1801. Can you please select 1801?
Monal S: Now, select that notebook file, 1801.
Monal S: Okay, and let's select on kernel.
Monal S: Select on kernel.
Monal S: Click on Python Environment.
Monal S: Okay, let's wait. Okay, it is not loading for you, so what you can do, in your terminal.
Monal S: Okay, do you have the zip I've shared you yesterday? Have you downloaded that zip resource? Yesterday's class?
Pandiselvam: One more night to yield.
Monal S: Not downloaded.
Pandiselvam: Okay, yeah, I have seen that, but I didn't download it.
Monal S: See if I can look.
Pandiselvam: You want me to download it now?
Monal S: Yeah, no, no, no.
Monal S: in the community, Is the community open?
Pandiselvam: Yes.
Monal S: Can you please go to our chat?
Pandiselvam: This latest set. No, no, no, no, no.
Monal S: Refresh, refresh the page, you will see at the end. Yeah, yeah, this one, this one. At the end, you can see my command.
Monal S: At the end, at the end of the chat, at the end.
Pandiselvam: Yeah, yeah.
Monal S: Copy this, copy this? No, no, just copy. Don't report. I know you were just trying.
Monal S: Copy this whole thing.
Monal S: Pop it, go to Terminal.
Monal S: First, this will not work directly. Can you paste this command in any of this notebook cell, just for rough notes?
Pandiselvam: Based in any of the notebook cells?
Monal S: No notebook you have in front of you, right?
Monal S: You can just paste it.
Pandiselvam: That, I'm not sure.
Monal S: okay…
Pandiselvam: This node.
Monal S: notebooks that is in front of you, those blacks, where you write code in Python.
Pandiselvam: Yeah, okay, here.
Monal S: invested, yeah, why not?
Pandiselvam: Just…
Monal S: paste any, okay? We will use it later.
Pandiselvam: Okay.
Monal S: go to VENV, click on VENV.
Monal S: In your file, click on VENV.
Monal S: dot VENV, click on that.
Monal S: Click on that.
Monal S: Did you create a .vnv of your own? We didn't use UV?
Monal S: Real fast.
Pandiselvam: I selected through UV only.
Monal S: Oh, HP, yours is, like, 7-8. No, you have deleted it.
Pandiselvam: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, see, just like I showed one person to create that VNV, will you be able to watch the recording and do it.
Pandiselvam: Okay, UV and VNB, right? Yeah.
Monal S: write UVVENV space, let's write test 1, test underscore 1.
Monal S: Press Enter. Because you deleted it, you don't even have virtual environment.
Monal S: Okay, now click on… okay, see? Select kernel, it is loaded.
Pandiselvam: Okay, okay, then, got it. Oh, I, I hope I didn't remove the manually.
Monal S: Yeah, yeah, yeah, you remove manually. But also, structure it, right now, the structure does not look good. You can see .vnv, like, level 1v, it all looks… it looks all over the place, alright?
Pandiselvam: Okay, okay, I will restructure business.
Monal S: Yeah, restructure this, okay? But don't restructure test 1. Don't create anything inside Test 1.
Pandiselvam: Okay, okay.
Monal S: Yeah, sure. Thank you.
Pandiselvam: Thank you.
Monal S: Alright, Sai. Sai Shanmuki?
Sai Shanmukhi: So sorry, Mona, it's actually a different, name I joined, actually.
Monal S: Yeah, sure enough.
Sai Shanmukhi: I just want to… I just want to clarify on one of,
Sai Shanmukhi: Use, I mean, the code which we had written, can I share?
Monal S: Cheers.
Monal S: Yes, Timmy?
Sai Shanmukhi: I'm not sure whether I'm sharing… Okay, you are sharing. So, can you go to this club entry conditions part?
Monal S: Fair?
Sai Shanmukhi: Club entry conditions…
Monal S: Okay, capital.
Sai Shanmukhi: move this thing.
Monal S: it would…
Sai Shanmukhi: Until here…
Monal S: is on top…
Sai Shanmukhi: Where percentage equaled attorney, you mentioned.
Monal S: Yeah, here, yes.
Sai Shanmukhi: So here, the statement says, like, person, should be over 18, right? So, here we had mentioned the condition as greater than or equal to
Sai Shanmukhi: Yes, sir.
Monal S: It means 18 is also fine. It means 18 is also fine.
Monal S: If person Age, if I say 18, it will also work.
Sai Shanmukhi: Otherwise, I am the same.
Monal S: Yeah, yeah.
Sai Shanmukhi: The statement says, like, should be over 18, so I got a little confused.
Monal S: See, it is totally up to us. If we say, okay, should be over 18 or equal.
Sai Shanmukhi: My code is correct.
Monal S: Right?
Sai Shanmukhi: If it is.
Monal S: Only over 18, then, then yes, you are correct.
Sai Shanmukhi: Yeah, yeah, yeah, that… okay, that's where I got confused with it.
Monal S: Okay.
Sai Shanmukhi: I should use SQL.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes. Okay, that was my bad.
Sai Shanmukhi: I was trying to understand that condition, so I was getting a little confused.
Monal S: That was my bad of me. This, I have not added, okay?
Sai Shanmukhi: Okay, okay. And one more thing, Mona, like, people are requesting, like, for a fast track, I mean, I'm not sure where the level which I have, it might be coping or what.
Sai Shanmukhi: What?
Monal S: What level do you think you're currently in?
Sai Shanmukhi: I mean, people are, I think most of the people are expedient when they're looking for a faster.
Monal S: What's going on now?
Sai Shanmukhi: I'm not done.
Monal S: Not experienced. Most of the people are not experienced.
Sai Shanmukhi: Yeah, even…
Monal S: other language, but not everyone is from technical. So, it is totally fine to be here. If you feel more confident at some point in time, you can again ask me, I will help you. We do have multiple.
Sai Shanmukhi: Yeah, I got it, but the request is, like, too fast track, I'm not sure.
Monal S: No, no, no. People are… people are actually confused that… why there are multiple videos. Should we Google Fast Track and other options? That is their main query.
Sai Shanmukhi: Okay.
Monal S: But yeah.
Sai Shanmukhi: Okay, one second.
Sai Shanmukhi: Okay, thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, guys, don't worry, you guys, your guys' names are coming.
Monal S: Jessica… Ishu? Ishu Goyal, you're next.
Ishu Goyal: Hey, hi Mulan. Am I audible?
Monal S: Yes, you're article.
Ishu Goyal: Yeah, connect at this side, and go to this session, it was great.
Ishu Goyal: I have one question, actually, it's regarding the UV and Anaconda. So, I just wanted to know which one is better in UV and Anaconda, as some people are using Anaconda. And, why are we using UV instead of Anaconda? As I see in one of the Udemy course, we have used this Anaconda.
Monal S: See, I personally have Conda in my system as well. I will show you. Okay. So it's my terminal. If I raise Conda, do I have Conda? I have Conda.
Monal S: Okay? If I show you my VS Code, if I select kernels, select another kernel.
Monal S: You will see all of this Mini Conda. These are all the environments of Miniconda, okay? So… Okay, so we can install both of the things, one at a time, I mean, at a time. Whatever, whatever is your liking. See, I will tell you what is the, thing, okay? Conda is also a package distributor.
Monal S: This is for people who know Conda, say, otherwise don't listen to it, otherwise you'll get confused. Conda is also a package manager, okay? Conda also helps you create environments, alright? UV is also a package manager. UV also helps you create environments, so both of them does the same job, yes?
Monal S: UV is written in Rust.
Monal S: And Rust is… Rust works very closely with C++ and hardware. UV allows parallel processing as well.
Monal S: When you install something, okay? Parallel processing, it allows. Conda does not uses it. Conda is a little heavy, UV is more light, but it does not have a cons, it does not have a pros or cons. It does not have a pros and cons, both of them are good.
Monal S: So, in production, if you want to use something light and quick with less installation, UV is good. If you want to deal with Conda and other things, there… because Conda also has many Conda, right?
Monal S: Miniconda is the lighter version of Anaconda.
Monal S: This one, Miniconduct. Both of them are also same. This one gives you more packages, this one gives you less packages, but you can install packages however you like.
Monal S: You can install, just like we install things with PIP,
Monal S: you can install things with Conda also. Conda maintains its own thing. You can also install with UV. So all of them are different tools. It's like, I should use VS Code.
Monal S: I… or I should use cursor, or I should use Notepad++, whatever is to your liking.
Monal S: But I have used UV because of parallel processing. When you download a lot of packages, right?
Ishu Goyal: UV can download all of them parallelly.
Monal S: But in Conda and others, they will download in sequential. Okay, and also, this is lightweight.
Monal S: I personally like Miniconda a lot, but, now I've started using UV.
Ishu Goyal: Okay, so, when I use both of them, at a single system, I mean, install them in a single system, so there will be no conflict in both of them, right?
Monal S: I'm also not getting any conflict. Are you able to see?
Ishu Goyal: Yes.
Monal S: I also have everything.
Ishu Goyal: Yeah, yeah.
Monal S: There is no conflict.
Ishu Goyal: See, if you understand what environments are.
Monal S: Invartments are nothing but an isolated system which has its own libraries, and a .exe file.exe file in Windows is nothing but those kernels.
Monal S: Okay. Alright?
Monal S: How'd it go?
Ishu Goyal: Yeah.
Monal S: Thank you. Yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: What?
Monal S: Pradeep, finally you are here. Hello, Pradeep.
Pradeep Barik: Yeah. Hi, I wanna.
Monal S: Hi, Proteep, yes.
Pradeep Barik: Am I everyone?
Monal S: You're audible.
Pradeep Barik: Yeah, it was a good session, actually.
Pradeep Barik: Yeah, I, I have query that,
Pradeep Barik: Today, actually, we just, like, you just, read us, like, non-primitive data types. So, today, just, I, we learned, least, but there are so many, like, set and.
Monal S: Not yet. We have just started to list a lot of things.
Pradeep Barik: Yeah, but I just, I just have a query that, will you, shall we, learn all the non-primitive data types, or at least easy enough for this course, like…
Monal S: No, no, we have to learn all. We will learn all.
Pradeep Barik: Okay, okay, that's the query I have, actually, because for machine learning, yeah.
Pradeep Barik: And in Bitwise operator also, I have some queries, like, in machine learning algorithm, actually, the, computer is, you, you told us, like, your computer is understanding 0 and 1. And, actually, BT is, Bitwise is, doing the same thing.
Pradeep Barik: So, like, why you, like, igno… like, not ignore, but, just,
Pradeep Barik: Tell, like, us, this is the…
Monal S: See, your question is, like, why we are even using Python when we can communicate with bitwise operator, 0.
Pradeep Barik: Yeah. Why Python is there?
Monal S: So that we don't have to communicate with bitwise operators.
Pradeep Barik: Okay, okay.
Monal S: Now, suppose you are an engineer. I'm just giving you an example. You are an engineer who does not know data science, but in your college project, you kind of want to simulate some kind of a CPU, a very small CPU, okay? Or very… some kind of an electronic component.
Monal S: At that time, the electronic component input is also bits. Electricity, yes?
Pradeep Barik: If you have those kind of input, can you also simulate those using Python, Bitwise, and other things?
Monal S: Using gates, NOR gate, XOR gate, yes?
Monal S: That time, you can use it.
Monal S: But we as a data scientist, we…
Monal S: I am ignoring… see, if I talk about Python as a programming language, if I teach you Python for 6 months, that will not be even enough.
Monal S: We are learning Python for… So that we can develop software for data science.
Monal S: Okay. But Python can also be used for NASA and other softwares. Are we going to learn all of that? No.
Pradeep Barik: No, no, yeah, I understand.
Monal S: Yep.
Pradeep Barik: Yeah.
Monal S: Thanks, thanks. Thanks, Mona.
Monal S: Thanks, brother.
Monal S: All right, Pagwan.
Monal S: Juan, you're next.
Monal S: Guys, hand raised are not getting less and less. I can see numbers are increasing.
Monal S: But I'm still here.
Monal S: Bhagan? Okay, Bhavan, I'm not able to hear you.
Bhagwan Gupta: I can hear you now. Yeah, there was some issue with my mic.
Monal S: Yeah, it's fine.
Bhagwan Gupta: Thank you, sir, and the session was really great. I have two questions. Basically, the first question related to course, we have two courses, you know, reflecting under the courses tab. One is the old one, Ultimate Data Science, and the, the…
Bhagwan Gupta: Second one is the current one. So, you know, my question was, if we parallelly, you know, complete the first one course, and also attending the live, you know, live classes from you, so will that.
Monal S: That will be a waste of time.
Monal S: I'm going to teach the same thing.
Monal S: If you learn Python again, and then watch Python again, why not watch two lectures of the progression one?
Monal S: You will be further into the course?
Monal S: Yeah, actually, I, you know, I haven't gone through the syllabus, so that's why I, like, I'll have a question, so…
Monal S: The bus is also a little different, but you will be able to get through either with V1, V2. And once the machine learning part is done, or deep learning, then you can join this batch whenever it is live. In the meantime, you can complete that. This batch will never be faster than V1, because we have started one year late.
Monal S: It is a different batch altogether. So you can complete all the parts there, but I will not suggest to go back and forth until you're learning something new here.
Bhagwan Gupta: No, I'll, you know, I'll be attending live sessions, which is more interactive, just because the course is there, so I thought, like, I'll clarify my doubts.
Monal S: That is for FastTrack, if you want. That is, like, additional thing which we two guys got. That's all.
Monal S: Okay.
Bhagwan Gupta: Sure. So, the second question which I have, you know, my VS Code is not working. I've installed UV and the VS Code as well.
Monal S: Have you tried whatever I'm showing to other people? Because I'm repeating the same thing. Have you tried all the things I've showed from past…
Bhagwan Gupta: Yeah, actually, I'm not able to, in fact, create the folder. Earlier, it was working, I don't know what's the issue. I've tried to figure out if you can take a moment.
Monal S: is here. And Rithik, you are next, okay? Rithik?
Monal S: Yours is next.
Bhagwan Gupta: Yeah, I'm sharing my screen, thank you.
Monal S: Interesting, Rebecca.
Bhagwan Gupta: So, here's, yeah, here's my screen.
Bhagwan Gupta: I've installed it, in fact, I'm trying to create folder.
Bhagwan Gupta: But it's not allowing me.
Monal S: What is this Python on versus…
Bhagwan Gupta: Oh, this… Which…
Monal S: Is this .zip.10A?
Monal S: I don't know, it was, can you click on File? Can you click on File? Can you click on File?
Monal S: Click on New Open Folder.
Monal S: Where is the folder? Okay, okay, no, no, no, no, yes.
Monal S: Yes, click on it.
Monal S: Click on… yes, just select folder, click on select folder.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay, okay.
Monal S: Go back, go back, go back, go back, go back, go back, go back.
Monal S: I'm not sure how you are arranging all of this, yes. Now go back, press back arrow.
Monal S: Yes. Now click on Classes Krishnak, just click on it, don't double-click.
Bhagwan Gupta: To click on Saturday.
Monal S: folder? Thread folder.
Monal S: Save.
Monal S: I think you opened something weird.
Bhagwan Gupta: I don't know, I'm listening.
Bhagwan Gupta: Cancel it out.
Monal S: No, no, you did something wrong.
Bhagwan Gupta: I'm not getting into audio.
Monal S: Click on file again, click on File again.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay.
Monal S: First Closure VS Core, first closure VS Core.
Monal S: You have a lot of things open here.
Monal S: Open again.
Monal S: Open VS Code.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay, my… Oh, there are multiple files, so here it is.
Bhagwan Gupta: You know, in fact, I've installed it myself.
Monal S: Closer.
Monal S: Can you close all the tabs that are present in the VS Code?
Bhagwan Gupta: No, it is not an issue, no.
Monal S: Can you see tabs?
Bhagwan Gupta: It's not just like a vocal.
Monal S: room, we have tabs, right? I can see your tabs.
Bhagwan Gupta: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I can see that.
Bhagwan Gupta: Close everything. Close everything.
Monal S: Yeah, don't save, don't save.
Monal S: Close everything.
Bhagwan Gupta: Good morning!
Bhagwan Gupta: So, this is closing one by one.
Monal S: You're… because you're working in app data, Something you did wrong.
Monal S: Yeah.
Bhagwan Gupta: I think so, I placed something wrong. That's right.
Monal S: It's fine. Close this.
Monal S: Now, click Open File, and then open that folder, Krishnakman. Open, go to File.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay.
Monal S: folder.
Monal S: No, no, open folder, not file.
Monal S: Cancel, cancel this operation, cancel this operation.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay.
Monal S: You have to navigate the Guam, okay?
Bhagwan Gupta: open for… okay, I mistakenly clicked on file.
Monal S: Yeah, now just click on, yeah, select folder, yes.
Bhagwan Gupta: Should I select the Kristen again?
Monal S: Not yet. Sarah Krishnak?
Monal S: necessary holder.
Bhagwan Gupta: Don't say that.
Monal S: Don't save, don't save, don't save, don't save.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay…
Bhagwan Gupta: I pressed on.
Monal S: Oh, see what a fake.
Monal S: I'm not so…
Bhagwan Gupta: I'm so sorry, so…
Monal S: It's totally.
Bhagwan Gupta: Yeah, I'm…
Monal S: Fine. But I will suggest to better see, practical live is good you create it, but start from where I was talking about how to create directories, what we should follow, because in practical life, you should be creating folders.
Bhagwan Gupta: Right? Just like I was doing.
Monal S: You created like me, that is good, that is good. But try to navigate to the VS Code, how to open folders, how to do things, then you will understand. Okay?
Bhagwan Gupta: Definitely, I, you know…
Bhagwan Gupta: Yes, sir. Okay, I was trying that, but somehow, you know, these things were not importing into this, so I was like, if I installed it wrong…
Monal S: whenever you click on save now, it was not redirecting, so you should cancel it, okay? It will not come now, it will not come.
Bhagwan Gupta: Okay, thank you so much, Melissa. I'll make sure to do it next.
Monal S: Yeah.
Bhagwan Gupta: Thank you.
Monal S: Thank you.
Bhagwan Gupta: Bye.
Monal S: Bye-bye.
Monal S: And then, Rithik?
Monal S: Retik?
Ritik kumar barnwal: Hey, hi Monal. It's Claudeville, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yeah, firstly, I'm so sorry for slamming over the chat, like… No, no, it's totally fine. Yeah, I understand, but I also have to communicate, right?
Monal S: Yeah, that's true.
Ritik kumar barnwal: So, actually, I just had a one doubt. See, first of all, you guys are putting a lot of efforts for creating this type of content for us, and of course, I'm just following Krishna from the last 3 years, I guess. So, I just had a one doubt, like, what should we do? Like, since you are, like, teaching on the live classes, should we follow the same, like, while you are doing the coding things over the VS Code and all the stuff? So, should we follow the same, like, we should
Ritik kumar barnwal: do coding at the simultaneously.
Monal S: I will tell you.
Monal S: What… I will tell you what I do, because everyone's story is different, everyone learns differently, right?
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yup.
Monal S: So, everyone needs to figure it out. Everyone who stayed till now, there are 75 people stay till now. So, everyone needs to figure it out what works for them. Some people like books. I personally, I have books, you can see books. And, I never went even page 10, because for some reason, that doesn't work for me.
Monal S: And in terms of that coding, when I started my coding, started learning coding, I was more interested in understanding, getting comfortable with what exactly is code.
Monal S: I started coding after 3 months after learning coding.
Monal S: my base, C, C++, okay? Little bit. So, what you can do, you can figure it out if, while writing, beside me, like, watching the live classes you wanted to write and practice it, if that may… if that is increasing your anxiety that I'm not able to do it, don't do it.
Monal S: But if you feel that you are comfortable doing it side-by-side, you're not… you're not losing focus, then do side-by-side coding. But if you're losing focus.
Monal S: I am already giving you what code I'm writing, yes.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yeah, that's funny.
Monal S: What you can do, you can just revise it once the class resource is uploaded.
Monal S: That's all?
Monal S: Practice it, change it, do permutation combinations on that. Resource will always be available if you want the original file, yes?
Ritik kumar barnwal: Okay.
Monal S: So do experimentation on the file which I provide, if that is the way you like. If you're not getting… if you're not feeling… feeling anxious that… what is going on in the live class? Did I miss something? Did I miss something? Then don't do side-by-side coding. Let's do it!
Monal S: It's totally.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Right.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yeah, actually, you know, why I ask this? Because, see, I've been, like, into tech field, like, I've been learning all these things since my college days, and I have, like, around total 3 years of experience in corporate, but not in the technical side.
Ritik kumar barnwal: So, you know, I just want to switch in that. And I even tried all the things, like, to, like, for some other… when I was doing the development things for the DS and all.
Ritik kumar barnwal: while, keeping the sessions and just doing the coding simultaneously, so I was not able to, cope up with that thing.
Ritik kumar barnwal: So, I was just not able to figure it out, so that's why.
Monal S: It's funny trick.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Okay, yeah.
Monal S: Same. That's good. So when I'm going to give you assignment from next week, everyone's going to give assignment, then you can do your coding, then there you can practice your skill, but if you're not able to do it alongside the class, don't do it. Don't at all try. Just look at the concept.
Monal S: Just look… because I'm the one writing the code, just look at the syntax and everything. No need to remember anything, ChatGPT is here, Google Gemini's here, who's going to write the code, but understand what is there, why it is there, alright?
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yeah, that's correct. And the last thing, Manal, I wanted to ask, so in this course, like, like, at the end of this course, you'll cover all the things, like, how you can build the SMS for everything in there, no?
Monal S: Everything.
Ritik kumar barnwal: So, yeah.
Monal S: Whatever we have promised, we always give more than that.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yeah, I know, like, because I'm following Chris from the last 3 years, and you know, like, I was very curious to learn AI, like, from being in a non-technical background, like, in a non-technical corporate experience, I would just want to switch my career into AI and all the things.
Monal S: Great, awesome.
Ritik kumar barnwal: Yeah, so yeah, that's all. Thanks, Monu. Thank you so much.
Monal S: Sure thing, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, Srinath, you're next.
Monal S: Do you not?
Shreenath: That's me.
Monal S: your queue is after Srinath. Yes, Srinath, yes.
Shreenath: Can you hear me? Yes, yes, Mono. So, I have just one quick question. First of all, thank you for the classes and the session, whatever you are conducting. So, I've just been… I've just created one project, and under the one project, I have created two environments. Okay, suppose environment 1, version… Python version 1.2, and second environment, version… Python version 2.0.
Shreenath: Now what we are… now what I am doing, I'm just changing the environment to version from 2.2 to 3.2.
Shreenath: So, what is happening here, under the environment 2, there is a one file, like PYEVENB.configure, where version info is not getting changed, that's the same.
Monal S: No, don't… create a new environment, why you want to change it? Create a new environment.
Shreenath: Okay.
Shreenath: Can I share my screen?
Monal S: Super.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Okay, when you're creating a new environment, the Python version is still the same, you're saying?
Monal S: You're not?
Shreenath: Hello?
Monal S: Hello? Yes.
Shreenath: Can you see my skin?
Monal S: It is not yet loaded. So the issue is, you are creating a new environment, but the Python is still the same, yes?
Shreenath: Yes, yes, yes. Okay.
Monal S: Every time.
Shreenath: I have crea… yeah, tell me.
Monal S: Okay. See, you do… I understand your issue. Are you able to see.
Shreenath: MSK.
Monal S: Can you show me again? Yes, yes.
Monal S: Okay.
Shreenath: Yeah.
Monal S: Alright, this is my terminal, let me open CMD.
Monal S: I don't know.
Monal S: And it was closed, yes, I don't want it Let me minimize a bit.
Monal S: How do I look at myself.
Monal S: Okay, so currently we are able to see this level 1, and here we are able to see that I have Python 3.1212, right? Correct. You are saying that you are changing version info here.
Shreenath: Yes. No, no, I'm not changing here. I am not changing here. I'm just, installing, UV.
Monal S: Okay, if you're installing something, let me install some dummy one.
Monal S: This is what you're doing?
Shreenath: Yes, yes, correct.
Monal S: Okay? Now, if you write this code again, what will happen?
Monal S: You are… did you remember that? UV…
Monal S: Do you remember that code which I shared before? I will show you that.
Shreenath: No, no, Monol, I think… I think under… different understanding. What I am doing, I have one project. Under one project, I have created two environments.
Monal S: environment, I'm also creating another environment.
Shreenath: another environment. Then, what I am doing now, I am changing the Python version for the.
Monal S: How are you?
Monal S: the Python version, how you're changing the Python version?
Monal S: What is the code you are changing the Python version?
Shreenath: just… I'm just doing the experiment. So, what time…
Monal S: No, you should not do like that, you should not do like that, okay? It might break something, because when we install something, the dependencies of those files also comes with us.
Monal S: Are you clear on that?
Monal S: So what we need to do, just, I will show you.
Monal S: That was weird, a second.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: UVPython list when I do, how many versions of Python I have in my system, you will see all of these Pythons, okay?
Monal S: These are all the Python lists available from the UV, but not in my system. These are in my system. You can see, this is what version? 3.14. This is 3.12. This is 3.12.
Shreenath: No.
Monal S: These are all the versions available in my sister, along with UV has those.
Monal S: If I do UV, V, and V, and just write dummy 1.
Shreenath: Yes.
Monal S: Alright? It will create with Python 3.1212. Why? Because in my UV, I've already selected it.
Monal S: So what I need to do? What I need to do, I need to pin the Python version.
Monal S: Do you remember the command where we used.
Shreenath: Yeah, yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. UB Python pin, Python button, yes.
Monal S: Jovi, Python, Pain, I will say, let's say, 3.14.
Shreenath: Yes, correct? Is the version pinned?
Shreenath: Yes.
Monal S: If you see, dummy 1 already has 3.12.
Shreenath: Yeah, because we don't want it.
Monal S: which we don't want, right? So I'm going to delete dummy one, and let's create… because now I paint the 3.14. If I create dummy one again, it was created with…
Monal S: 3.14, are you able to see in my terminal?
Shreenath: Yes, yes, correct.
Monal S: If I do W1 now, are you able to see 3.14?
Shreenath: Okay, you mean we need to delete that environment again? We need to pin it first, because UV, how you will know what Python you want?
Monal S: First, pin the UV, then do the creation. Done.
Shreenath: Okay, okay. Okay, okay, okay. I'm just, I'm just saying it will be, automatically, will be changed in that, computation file?
Monal S: No, no.
Monal S: C.
Shreenath: Okay.
Monal S: If you, if you download and… if you want to use latest version of Android, can you change the file name and Android will change? No, you need to download the whole files.
Shreenath: Okay, okay, okay. It's me, we need to… first, we need to pin the letters, but then delete that environment, and okay, okay, thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Yes, okay.
Monal S: Okay, HP, you are… Not HP. HP, you are next.
Monal S: That's P?
Monal S: Did we already talk before?
hp: Hello?
Monal S: Hello? HP?
hp: Yeah, I'm out well.
Monal S: No, no. Oh, yes, hello, you have heard about it.
hp: So, yeah, my question is, like, I'm aiming for Gen AI developer or Gen AI engineering role.
hp: So, will this, Ultimate DS course will be enough, or, after completing this, I need to do any further thing?
Monal S: Enough depends on the industry and where you're applying. If you want to apply at Google, this is not enough.
Monal S: If you want to apply at startups, if you want to apply at MNC, this is enough.
Monal S: Okay, this will… this will be enough, right?
Monal S: This will be enough, but if tomorrow some new topic requires, What will you do?
hp: We need to let the… yeah.
Monal S: Alright? So if something is not a part of the course and the industry, it'll change.
Monal S: It is you who have to do the work. But at current environment, current, for 3-4 months, this course is more than enough.
Monal S: Okay? But if you want to become
Monal S: test engineer, then I need to learn more things.
Monal S: This is a beginner-intermediate level, but for advanced level, we have different things.
Monal S: Okay?
hp: Okay, one more question I have, like, my answer introduced some,
hp: AI Automation, Udemy course, so we can do parallel with this, and…
Monal S: that does not require coding. If you have time, you can do paralleling.
hp: Okay. And one more, like, a few more,
hp: Like, multiple, courses that, my answer showed. So, what will be the sequence of…
Monal S: Hey, first, as.
hp: If I want to do.
Monal S: are told that today Manchester shared one course, which tells you AI plus ANIT. So, if you complete that, you will understand… you will have an understanding of AI. And if you want to go further and specialize into Annet L, then go to the course which Manzar previously shared 2-3 days back.
Monal S: Are you clear?
hp: Okay.
Monal S: That is a specialization of NATN, the current course which mine are shared in this class today. Here, it is more about AI, what is NATN, what we can do with those. It is more about understanding all the things. Just like Ultimate Data Science, Ultimate Data Science gives you understanding of everything. But if you want to learn REG specifically, then we have a REG course.
Monal S: Are you able to understand now?
hp: Yeah, yeah. So that will be part of Gen AI, that init and something?
Monal S: NATAN is a part of automation. It is not a JNEI. NATN automation uses GenAI. That's why you need to understand what exactly things are. HP, are you clear?
hp: Okay, got it, Mundo. Thank you.
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: Tajesh, you are next.
Monal S: Guys, please lower your hand once you're done.
sajesh nair: Yeah, hi, hi one.
Monal S: Hey, Sajesh, yes.
sajesh nair: Yeah, manila, I wanted to discuss on the yesterday's assignment, which you had given.
sajesh nair: Regarding that, creating that.
Monal S: From the terminal, we need to create that, you know, so can I once share my screen? I mean.
sajesh nair: The environment, everything has got resolved.
Monal S: I just want to show you, there is one command.
Monal S: Okay, I'm promoting it to panelists. Please join.
Monal S: Yeah, that's cool.
Monal S: Kaushik, you… we have 3 people, and guys, after 3 people, I will not take. Satish is the last person. After Satish, I will not take any other questions. Because if you keep raising by understanding the number, it will… it is going to create
Monal S: Unnecessary chaos for me.
Monal S: Satish is the last person, Kaushik is the last second, Venkata is the first one after this. Yes, tell me.
sajesh nair: Yeah, can you see my screen?
Monal S: I can see your screen.
sajesh nair: Okay, so yesterday's assignment, which you had said that, you know, we need to create the folders in this way.
Monal S: Yeah, you should not create in Level 1. It is a separate assignment. Assignment… don't mix up your assignment in this level, because here you are.
sajesh nair: No, no, no, I've created separate… that I've created a separate.
Monal S: Guys.
sajesh nair: For assignment, I've just created separately.
Monal S: That's great, that's great, awesome.
sajesh nair: Yeah, so I have created this kind of steps in that key, how we can create, and I've created it separately itself.
sajesh nair: So, in that, one of the command to create a IEPN by file was copycon, and the name of the file which I wanted to create. So, basis that I've created today's lecture… today's class lecture, CopyCon 18th Gen IPN by.
Monal S: That's great. That's great.
sajesh nair: So, yeah, so I've created it in this way, but, you know, when I was trying to, you know, search for any codes in ChatGPT now, most of them are providing it in PowerShell.
sajesh nair: But, you know…
Monal S: You need to write terminal. If you need to specifically write it, PowerShell uses a different kind of a command. If you write CMD in Windows, and I want command for that, you will get command from CMD.
sajesh nair: Okay, but you said we should not use PowerShell, so what is the difference?
Monal S: No, see, PowerCell uses a different command. Terminal is… the CMD is very lightweight. PowerShell is used more for… it is more for advanced user. So I want… I want you all to be familiar with some kind of a base coding, okay? Later, when you get senior.
Monal S: You will even forget Windows, and everything will be Linux command. Mac uses Linux-based terminal.
Monal S: And Linux already uses Linux, the command will also change, but this way you will understand that, how to work with Terminal to just move around the OS. That's the main goal. Goal is not you to learn Windows. Goal is to use…
sajesh nair: command, right? This is the correct command.
Monal S: I… when I was showing in my terminal, I was showing you something else. This is a different command. There are different ways to create a file, okay?
sajesh nair: Okay, this isn't CMD only, I've created in CMD.
Monal S: Yeah, I was using something else, but this is a different command. Okay, it's fine. If you're able to create it, note it down your notes, it's fine.
sajesh nair: Yeah, I've noted it down, but I'm not sure if this error is coming, I'm not sure why this is coming, so I just wanted to show you if I'm doing it correctly.
Monal S: No.
sajesh nair: Can you see this?
Monal S: This is while creating, this is while.
sajesh nair: No, no, no, now when I saw this, it was showing some problems in 17 and 18 Jan.
Monal S: Because you're getting invalid syntax, it means something you have written code incorrectly.
Monal S: Okay. In the…
sajesh nair: the system, okay?
Monal S: Yes, if you go to…
sajesh nair: Yes, line or column, is it this way? How do we read this?
Monal S: This is… I personally don't use that problems one. Are you able to run the code in the… are you able to run code in the notebook?
sajesh nair: Yeah, yeah, I can, I can run it, but I'm not sure if it is covered the problem.
Monal S: Don't worry about these problems, ignore it.
sajesh nair: not an issue, because later the VS Code should not get, you know.
Monal S: No, no, no, no, no, it's totally fine.
sajesh nair: Yeah, yeah, thanks.
Monal S: Yeah? Yeah.
sajesh nair: design.
Monal S: Simple.
Monal S: Alright,
Monal S: Then we have… Venkrita? Venkrita?
Monal S: You know, the last third.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Hi, Munel, thanks for… hi.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Just, like, I have one question. So, yesterday… I mean, like, I missed yesterday's session, but I've gone through the videos and followed to create the, you know…
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: kernel. So currently, what I have done, I have created two, folders, one is level 0 and level 1.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: And, if I'm going to the folder level 1, I'm able to enable the kernel, you know, version, whatever I'm doing. But if I'm coming to the practical, folder, if I want to switch, you know, I can see both the folders now, level 0 and level 1.
Monal S: That is the error which we have seen. For some reason, our VS Code, along with UV, is not able to look into two different folder, two levels of folder, okay? So go in one, work with one. And in real world, when you create a project, project is always a single level.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Okay, okay, yeah. Single level, I'm able to do, that's not an issue.
Monal S: That is the issue. I will need to check why VS Code is not able to handle it. Not just VS Code, maybe we will check with some other ID, but that is the issue with VS Code and UV. It is not able to find the packet. UV works, but locating it is kind of creating an issue.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Yeah, yeah, yeah, absolutely fine, like, see, if I want to activate the level 0, I'm able to do the activate, I'm able to run the, files, but only thing, the kernel, it is using the global one, not the, you know?
Monal S: is not able to find the coroner which we created, right? Yes.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Yes, yes, yes, that is the part.
Monal S: Yeah, make sure that you create in the same level.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: I did the same level, yes.
Monal S: Yeah, that's good, Venkuta, that's good.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Yeah, yeah, that's it, like, okay, it is something problem with, you know, other than that, my, my, yeah, whatever setup I did, it is not an issue, so that's all, yeah, yeah.
Monal S: That's good, that's different, you know.
Venkata thrinadhareddy koyya: Yeah, yeah, thank you very much, yeah, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, Kaushik, finally you are here, last second is Kaushik.
Monal S: Hashik?
Monal S: Thanks for staying till now.
Monal S: I know you're fixing your mic.
Kausik Khanra: We just… Hello, can you hear me?
Monal S: Hello? Hey, Kashy, yes, I can hear you.
Kausik Khanra: Yeah, yeah, thanks. So I have a question, like, you showed how to pin that a particular version of Python in UV, right? So, UV pin, that is the command is, UVPython pin 3.12, or something like that.
Kausik Khanra: My question is, I did that, and that's fine, but when you were creating a new environment with a different version of Python, have you showed that how to do that?
Monal S: I just showed now with PIN, right?
Kausik Khanra: Yes, that's fine, but my question is 3.12, that is pinned, okay, there. And I have created one environment with that particular Python version. And now I want to create another environment with a different version, so…
Monal S: Install the Python. Now, first you need to install the Python version using UVPython. We have seen that code, right?
Kausik Khanra: Yes.
Monal S: in the lecture 1. You need to install the version of Python which is not available in Fishtown. Once it is installed, pin that version, and then create the environment.
Kausik Khanra: Yeah, I did that, but my question is, when I'm creating another environment, do I need to delete the previous environment?
Monal S: No, you don't delete it. I deleted it because I don't want all the environments. I only want the.
Kausik Khanra: Got it, got it, got it.
Kausik Khanra: I can create multiple environments.
Monal S: Yeah, create tons of it. Yeah, create 10 environments you like, but make sure that the names are different.
Kausik Khanra: Yeah, definitely, yeah. That answers my questions. Thanks, Muno.
Monal S: That's accurate. Thank you.
Monal S: Alright, finally, Satish, last person, and we all, Done. Yes, Satish?
Satish Yadav: Hello, munar.
Monal S: Awesome profile picture, by the way. Is this you?
Satish Yadav: Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm…
Monal S: Yeah, that's great.
Satish Yadav: So, finally, my chance come.
Monal S: Yes, finally, you're the last one.
Satish Yadav: Yeah. So, can I share the screen?
Monal S: Yes, first, tell you what is your issue.
Satish Yadav: The issues in the file section, though my file section is very meshed up, my .vnv file…
Satish Yadav: Any issues?
Monal S: Join as a panelist, join as a panelist.
Satish Yadav: Yeah, once again, yeah.
Satish Yadav: So, here you can see… Hello.
Monal S: I'm not able to see your screen.
Satish Yadav: month.
Satish Yadav: Now you can see.
Monal S: I can… I think it will load after 2-3 seconds. Let's speed.
Monal S: It's not yet.
Satish Yadav: Excellent.
Monal S: I can see people answer how many Python lectures more, guys, we have started Python in, and you guys are saying how many more Python lectures?
Monal S: Here to learn something or complete something?
Monal S: Others?
Monal S: Whoever stayed till now, guys, are you here to learn something or complete something?
Satish Yadav: Is it visible?
Monal S: But there's not yet.
Monal S: Learn, thank you. There are a lot of people who are here to learn.
Monal S: But there are people who just want this course to be end tomorrow.
Monal S: So that they can apply to the jobs.
Monal S: The skills works like that? Skill works like adding hashtag in your resume?
Satish Yadav: Oh, it's…
Monal S: Yes, I can see your screen now, yes.
Satish Yadav: So, there's a file section.
Monal S: Hmm, it is all over the place. Where is your file? You have created VNV in Site 17, you have created VNV as a level 1 VNV.
Satish Yadav: when I… when I create a file, so it's going in VNV.
Monal S: It is not going, actually. It happens, but you should not create it. You can drag and drop outside, but I will suggest… see what I will suggest you, okay? Yeah, yeah. You have your main files, which I'm sending as a resource.
Monal S: Keep it in the download, delete everything, start, just, like, very simple. Because right now, you have to fix a lot of things, and UB creating an environment takes 3 seconds, yes?
Satish Yadav: Yeah.
Monal S: So it's better to delete everything, create environment, never touch, never create anything inside that environment. And I told you to create how to name an environment.
Monal S: If you don't name an environment, it will be .venv.
Monal S: Yes, if you want to name environment, you will write UV, VENV, and then the name of the environment, that command. Yes?
Monal S: This is a lot, yep.
Satish Yadav: What is here happening, butler?
Satish Yadav: I want… when I select this, this, kernel, the code is running, not… not running yet.
Satish Yadav: But…
Monal S: It's because the environment got deleted.
Satish Yadav: Oh.
Monal S: You can see, the kernel failed to start as Python enrollment. It is not able to find 3.12.12.
Satish Yadav: Click on level.
Monal S: Level 1, click on Level 1.
Monal S: No.
Satish Yadav: algorithm.
Monal S: It might work.
Satish Yadav: He's, the problem.
Monal S: Don't install, always install, always install. If you don't install it, it will not work. It will take some time.
Satish Yadav: The pop-up says.
Monal S: Okay, were you able to see the code, or, see, please copy and paste the command which I sent in the group.
Monal S: Okay. In our community, okay, check that. And once you install that environment, I will give you your task, okay?
Monal S: Wait, Satish, you can take the screenshot in our chat, okay?
Monal S: Okay. Satish.
Monal S: Can you please say hi so that I can write the scene for you?
Satish Yadav: From Zoom, in Zoom.
Monal S: Yeah, in Zoom chat, can you please say hi?
Satish Yadav: We'll ask.
Monal S: Delete everything.
Monal S: Second… create VNP with a name.
Monal S: You know how to activate an environment from terminal?
Satish Yadav: No.
Monal S: Okay, you need to watch recordings, Satish.
Satish Yadav: What… what? Yes.
Monal S: Yesterday's doubt session, if you watch yesterday's doubt session, I was the same,
Monal S: Activate the environment, okay? Yeah. Activate… I'm just going to write the steps, you can ask ChatGPT also, okay?
Satish Yadav: Okay, okay, okay.
Monal S: always use CMD, okay? Okay, you're in Mac, right?
Satish Yadav: Right, right.
Monal S: courtesy. That's fine.
Monal S: From terminal, then… Use this command which I'm using.
Monal S: And then… Fifth?
Monal S: Use notebooks.
Monal S: Are you able to see the chat?
Satish Yadav: Yeah, yeah.
Monal S: Send to everyone, okay?
Satish Yadav: So first, I have to delete everything, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes. Take a first… capture this from your phone, and then solve it later, okay?
Satish Yadav: Okay, got it.
Monal S: You will be able to do it, Satish. And there are people in our community which will help you. Now I will ask each and every one, because it's not you, because other people have done it so many times. They will also help you, okay?
Satish Yadav: Okay, one second, I can see the screen.
Satish Yadav: No, okay, done.
Satish Yadav: Thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, you're.
Satish Yadav: Give him a response.
Monal S: Yeah, thank you.
Satish Yadav: Have a nice team.
Monal S: Hey, you too. Have a nice day.
Monal S: Alright guys, we are finally done, and thank you very much, guys, for joining today's session. This is end of our first week.
Monal S: And we have learned a lot of things. We are going to learn a lot of things in Wednesday as well. It is going to be short, be prepared, make sure your environment is working, make sure that everything is, you have revised everything.
Monal S: And that's all. Thank you, guys, thank you.
Monal S: Thanks for joining today's session. See you, bye-bye guys, bye-bye.
Monal S: Yes, thank you, guys.
Monal S: Right.